avant que la vidéo ne commence j'ai une
question à vous poser vous croyez
vraiment que les gens ont lu tous les
livres dont ils parlent bien sûr que non
sinon on ne pourrait pas parler de grand
chose
ah oui il y a 24 heures dans une journée
et il faut travailler manger dormir et
sortir le chien
[Musique]
donc le secret de la culture générale ce
n'est pas de lire des livres c'est quoi
alors en fait il n'y a pas un seul
secret il y en a 5 les étudiants et les
personnes les plus cultivés les profs et
les intellectuels connaissent ces cinq
secrets savez vous avez lu Ronan comme
moi mais il se garde bien d'en parler
les gens qui les découvrent réussissent
à développer rapidement et facilement
leur culture générale parce que leur
rapport au savoir a changé et une fois
qu'ils appliquent les cinq secrets ils
comprennent toutes les références des
personnes cultivées ils savent
s'exprimer avec profondeur sur n'importe
quel sujet il brille et par leur culture
dans les conversations et dans les
débats et ils ont le recul nécessaire
pour faire preuve d'esprit critique ça
vous intéresse et bien je vous révèle
les cinq secrets et je vous explique
comment les appliquer dès aujourd'hui
pour vous cultiver dix fois plus
rapidement sans vous prendre la tête
pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit sur celui qui est dans la
description de la vidéo c'est l'histoire
de 10 secondes donc faites le maintenant
et vous pourrez découvrir le le premier
secret qui vous attendra bien au chaud
dans votre boîte mail après avoir
regardé cette vidéo voilà voilà je vous
ai dit ce que je voulais vous dire bonne
vidéo
[Musique]
première référence de la démocratie en
Amérique Alexis de Tocqueville
en 2004 l'écrivain français
Bernard-Henri Lévy BHL pour les intimes
accès apte une proposition du magazine
américain vit Atlantic momfly faire un
long voyage en Amérique sur les traces
d'Alexis de Tocqueville plus de 170 ans
plus tard pour donner à l'Amérique un
nouveau diagnostic extérieur sur l'état
de la démocratie
American Vertigo le livre qui compile
les chroniques de BHL sera un
best-seller aux États-Unis de la
démocratie en Amérique est une référence
incontournable en sciences politiques
parce que c'est la première analyse
approfondie de la réalité démocratique
c'est certain un livre de philosophie
politique cartocville parle de l’essence
et de l'idéal de la politique mais il
est un précurseur de la science
politique dans la mesure où il produit
une étude systématique du système
politique démocratique des forces à
l'oeuvre dans ce système ainsi que de la
relation entre ce système et les
mentalités de la démocratie en Amérique
est subdivisée en deux tomes d'environ
500 pages chacun autrement dit c'est
pour les courageux le premier tome
examine la démocratie façonne le
gouvernement et la vie politique aux
États-Unis le second se concentre sur
l'influence de la démocratie sur la
société civile et évoque les risques de
ce régime politique comme les auteurs du
19e siècle Tocqueville commet souvent
des phrases longues et complexes sont
styles et donc exigeants pour un lecteur
du 21e siècle
quels sont les idées essentielles de la
démocratie en Amérique qui ont un
intérêt spécifique pour la science
politique il y a tout d'abord l'enjeu de
l'association Tocqueville note dans le
tome 2 que les Américains ont une forte
tendance à s'associer l'Amérique est
critique et le pays du monde où l'on
attiré le plus de parties de
l'association quel que soit leur âge ou
leur mentalité les individus participent
à une multitude d'associations petites
ou grandes pour défendre leurs intérêts
leurs valeurs ou leurs croyances en
France en comparaison c'est le
gouvernement qui intervient pour faire
ce que font les citoyens américains en
s'associant les Français se méfient des
groupes d'intérêts c'est pourquoi il les
subordonne au pouvoir politique en
revanche les Américains font confiance
au groupe d'intérêts indépendants et
estime même qu'il contribue à la
vitalité démocratique la puissance de
l'opinion publique en démocratie est une
autre idée essentielle du livre pour
Tocqueville l'opinion publique est le
pouvoir dominant aux États-Unis et c'est
ce qui fait de la souveraineté du peuple
une réalité de chaque jour mais comment
expliquer cette domination de l'opinion
publique c'est un effet pervers du
fonctionnement des régimes démocratiques
étant donné que les citoyens sont égaux
la règle de la majorité et le seul moyen
pratique pour prendre des décisions
concernant le destin collectif et alors
les citoyens survalorisent l'opinion de
la majorité il risque donc de l'imposer
aux minorités avec une intransigence qui
dépasse celle des régimes autoritaires
c'est ce que Tocqueville appelle la
tyrannie de la majorité une troisième
idée importante pour la science
politique c'est la décentralisation
c'était un enjeu très discuté en France
au moment de la rédaction du livre
Tocqueville estime que la distribution
du pouvoir entre de nombreux niveaux et
organes est un élément essentiel du
succès de la démocratie américaine tout
d'abord cela empêche bien sûr la
tyrannie puisque le pouvoir n'est pas
concentré ensuite cela permet de prendre
de meilleures décisions parce que les
décideurs sont proches des citoyens
concernés par leur décision enfin la
décentralisation incite les citoyens à
s'engager dans la gouvernance locale en
résumé elle protège la liberté et rend
les citoyens meilleurs
de la démocratie en Amérique deviendra
une référence incontournable en sciences
politiques à plusieurs égards en premier
lieu l'approche intellectuelle de
Tocqueville est un modèle il a fait une
étude de terrain entre guillemets il
réfléchit avec le recul des passionnés
d'un scientifiques il met la sociologie
l'histoire et le droit en deuxième lieu
de la démocratie en Amérique traite déjà
de certains thèmes majeurs de la science
politique tels les groupes d'intérêts la
culture politique la distribution du
pouvoir et bien sûr la démocratie en
troisième lieu les conclusions de
Tocqueville sont toujours valables de
nos jours
les Américains reconnaissent dans de la
démocratie en Amérique une image fidèle
de leur pays il faut dire que
contrairement à BHL Tocqueville ne
s'était pas contenté de rencontrer
l’élite il avait également fréquenté des
fermiers des artisans et des petits
commerçants
[Musique]
deuxième référence qu'est-ce qu'une
nation d'Ernest Renan
Carl Deutsch un Tchèque et qui a été
prof de science politique dans les plus
prestigieuses aux universités
américaines à caricaturer la définition
de la nation de Renan en disant je cite
une nation est un groupe de personnes
unies par une vision
erronée du passé et la haine de leur
voisin c'est une caricature mais c'est
vrai que Ronan met en évidence la part
de croyance sur laquelle repose une
nation qu'est-ce qu'une nation est une
référence incontournable en sciences
politiques parce que c'est le socle
intellectuel des travaux sur le
nationalisme Renan rejette les fantasmes
qui sont couramment associés à l'idée de
nation ce faisant il permet d'étudier ce
mode de groupement comme il l'appelle
sans que l'idéologie ne déforme la
réalité ce livre est court est lisible
parce qu'il est tiré d'une conférence
donnée à la Sorbonne en 1882 une
conférence ne peut pas durer 10 heures
et le conférencier doit faire un effort
pour conserver l'attention de son public
les phrases sont parfois longues et les
références historiques ne sont pas
toujours évidentes mais rien
d'insurmontable la démonstration est
divisée en trois parties Renan retrace
d'abord l'origine historique de la
nation il invalide ensuite les
conceptions qui font de la Nation sur
des critères prétendument objectif et
montre ainsi ce que la nation n'est pas
enfin il donne sa propre définition en
proposant une articulation originale
entre un peuple et son histoire
quels sont les principales idées à
retenir pour la science politique en
premier lieu la nation n'est pas une
entité fixe définie par des critères
objectifs ni la race qui est une chimère
ni la langue ni la religion ne
permettent de fonder une nation il
s'agit en réalité d'une innovation
historique il n'y avait pas de nations
dans l'Antiquité ce sont les invasions
germaniques qui ont divisé l'Empire
romain d'Occident en nation en imposant
des dynasties et des aristocraties
militaires or les nouvelles entités
politiques n'avaient pas d'unité raciale
bien au contraire elles ont fait
fusionner différentes populations la
deuxième idée essentielle pour la
science politique et que le fondement de
la nation est psychologique c'est pour
ça que Renan écrit que la nation et je
cite une âme un principe spirituel la
réalité de la nation repose en dernière
instance sur le désir la volonté et dire
non et le sentiment d'appartenance de
ses membres pour être plus précis le
phénomène psychologique à deux
composantes d'une part l'adhésion au
passé de la communauté à son héritage
historique d'autre part le désir de
perpétuer cet héritage par la vie
commune vouloir faire de grandes choses
ensemble écrire non
la troisième idée essentielle de la
conférence est celle qui a occasionné la
caricature de carld Deutsch le sentiment
d'appartenance partagé par tous les
membres de la nation reposent en partie
sur l'erreur historique l'essence d'une
nation écrit Renan et que tous les
individus et beaucoup de choses en
commun et aussi que tous et oubliés bien
des choses France est par exemple devenu
le nom du pays alors même qu'il n'était
entré qu'une imperceptible minorité de
France Renan va même jusqu'à dire que le
travail des historiens menace l'idée de
nationalité
ces conclusions ont permis à la
réflexion de la science politique de
prendre beaucoup de recul par rapport à
la mythologie de la nation l'histoire
montre que les formes de la société
humaine sont très variées grande
agglomération tribus cités
sans patrie nation Confédération parenté
raciale ou linguistique etc revenant et
comme Tocqueville un précurseur de la
science politique dans la mesure où il
étudie lui à travers l'histoire la
réalité politique il est encore
précurseur dans la mesure où il étudie
cette réalité politique sur la longue
durée contrairement au journaliste par
exemple
l'influence de qu'est-ce qu'une nation
dépasse la seule science politique en
effet cette conférence est la source
principale de la conception de la nation
qui prévaut désormais dans les opinions
publiques occidentales l'idée de nation
a perdu une bonne partie de son crédit
au 20e siècle mais elle conserve une
légitimité à travers la conception de
Renan pour faire simple on dit que c'est
la conception française subjective donc
ouverte et on oppose cette conception
dite française à la conception dite
allemande car théorisée au début du XIXe
siècle par le philosophe fisht
conception allemand de dite objectif
donc fermé et c'est cette conception
dite allemande que les opinions
publiques occidentales disqualifie
désormais comme xénophobe
troisième référence les partis
politiques de Robert miquels
dans la chute de la maison Mélenchon un
essai publié fin 2019 le politologue
Thomas Guénolé accuse Jean-Luc Mélenchon
de diriger son parti la France insoumise
comme un dictateur alors même et qu'il
plaît de 116 pour une vraie démocratie
vous allez voir que le sociologue
allemand Robert Mickel avait expliqué
cette contradiction 100 ans plus tôt ce
livre les partis politiques est une des
références sur les rapports de pouvoir
au sein des organisations politiques
dans le détail Mikel c'est analyse à
l'émergence de parties ouvriers dans les
démocraties de masse et il en tire des
conclusions sur la réalité de la
démocratie c'est bien de la science
politique car la réflexion est nourrie
par les contacts de Michael avec des
partis politiques et des syndicats en
Allemagne et en Italie
la nouvelle traduction française de son
travail désormais intitulé sociologie du
parti dans la démocratie moderne cette
nouvelle traduction française représente
un pavé de plus de 800 pages comme les
auteurs de son époque Michael se
rassemblent de longues phrases en de
longs paragraphes mais il y a pire ça
reste lisible le vocabulaire n'est pas
trop technique les références
historiques sont plutôt classiques et le
style est assez clair
ce livre est souvent résumé à l’idée de
la loi des reins de l'oligarchie et
c'est largement suffisant pour votre
culture générale Robert miquels a trouvé
cette loi en constatant une
contradiction pour parler comme les
marxistes d'un côté les organisations
ouvrières affirment leur attachement à
la démocratie et fonctionne avec les
attributs de la pratique démocratique
mais de l'autre côté leur dirigeants ne
change pas ils ont tous les mêmes
profils et il se sert les coudes comment
expliquer cette contradiction l'origine
en est que les partis politiques se
bureaucratisent comme tout organisation
plus il s'agrandissent plus le travail
se divise et plus les décisions se
complexifient impersonnel administratif
spécialisé et tout particulièrement
nécessaire pour la mobilisation
politique et le fonctionnement quotidien
du parti or les administrateurs ont
besoin de connaissances spécifiques
juridiques économiques etc et de
compétences préparation de discours
rédaction de textes divers etc or cela
demande une formation que ne peuvent pas
suivre les Prolé taires c'est pour ça
que les intellectuels sont si importants
dans les parties ouvriers seul le
socialiste d'origine bourgeoise écrit
Robert miquels possède ce qui manque
encore totalement au prolétariat le
temps et les moyens de faire son
éducation politique la liberté physique
de se transporter d'un endroit à un
autre et l'indépendance matérielle sans
laquelle l’exercice d'une action
politique au sens vrai et propre du mot
est inconcevable
le problème c'est que ces élites
bureaucratiques vont s'émanciper elles
font prévaloir leur intérêt de cast sur
l'intérêt originel du parti concrètement
elle focalise la stratégie du mouvement
sur la conquête de trophées électoraux
et de postes de pouvoir au sein des
institutions établies le discours est
toujours révolutionnaire mais l'action
est celle d'un parti d'opposition un
parti que Michael scalifie de
conservateurs la logique du
développement d'une organisation aboutit
donc à une inversion des rapports
l'organisation affirme Michaels et ce
qui donne lieu à la domination des élus
sur les électeurs des mandataires sur
les Mandans des délégués sur les
délégants et c'est après cette phrase
que Michael c'est écrit sa fameuse
formule qui dit organisation dit
oligarchie
or cette conclusion ne vaut pas qu'à
l'intérieur du parti en effet une
démocratie est un vaste système avec son
organisation donc comme dans un parti
politique des élites dirigeantes
émergent puis derrière de belles paroles
elle substitue leur intérêt qui est de
rester au pouvoir afin d'en conserver
les avantages elle substitue leur
intérêt à celui du peuple normalement le
peuple peut changer ses responsables
politiques mais ceux-ci entravent le
renouvellement des élites dirigeantes
ils empêchent notamment l'émergence de
concurrents issus de la masse populaire
pour Mickel c'est la nécessaire
organisation d'un système démocratique
rend donc impossible la démocratie
elle-même c'est pour ça qu'il dit qu'il
écrit je cite avec l'intention de
démolir quelques-unes des faciles et
superficielles illusions démocratiques
avec une telle conclusion le livre a eu
une influence limitée en sciences
politiques comme la teste le fait que
les manuels évoque rapidement la loi des
reins de l'oligarchie est pourtant
pertinente pour analyser tout type
d'organisation les entreprises les
syndicats les administrations publiques
et bien sûr les partis politiques
seulement une organisation ne peut pas
perdurer si les membres pensent que leur
élite agit pour son propre compte même
si c'est vrai il est donc naturel que le
monde académique des démocratises
occidentales ne soient pas enthousiaste
à l'égard d'une théorie qui conclut que
la démocratie est une illusion
entretenue par les dirigeants politiques
après Michael se ne diabolise pas la
démocratie comme Pareto ils sont tous
les deux membres de l'école italienne de
sociologie des élites comme Pareto
Michel se voit les régimes politiques
comme Pareto Michel se voit les régimes
politiques comme des systèmes de
sélection et de légitimation de l'élite
dirigeante et à cet égard la démocratie
est un moindre mal parce que de toute
manière la masse populaire est passive
et a besoin d'un leader déçu par la
démocratie et le socialisme miquels
embrasse finalement le fascisme en 1928
ce qui lui permet d'obtenir un poste de
professeur à l'université cette
conversion est peut-être une autre
raison de l'influence limitée de son
livre en sciences politiques
quatrième référence tableau politique de
la France de l'Ouest d'André Siegfried
on évoque parfois l'adage ceux qui ne
savent pas faire enseignent pour se
moquer de ceux qui enseignent dans un
domaine où ils ont eux-mêmes échoué je
connais par exemple quelqu'un qui a été
embauché comme prof de stratégie dans
une école de commerce avec pour seul
expérience une période d'essai non
renouvelée dans un cabinet de conseils
en stratégie peu prestigieux on pourrait
aussi appliquer l'adage à André
Siegfried inspiré par l'exemple de son
père qui a été maire député et ministre
il se présente au moins quatre fois à
une élection dans les années 1900 et il
échoue à chaque fois un an après son
dernier échec il abandonne tout ambition
politique et devient prof à l'École
libre des sciences politiques l'ancêtre
de Sciences Po où il avait lui-même
étudié et quelques années plus tard il
écrit un ouvrage fondateur de la science
politique française en particulier sur
la question des élections
son tableau politique de la France de
l'Ouest est plus précisément considéré
comme l’œuvre fondatrice de ce qu'on
appelle la géographie électorale la
première phrase du livre en est
emblématique je cite j'ai remarqué
souvent dans les élections que les
opinions politiques sont sujettes à une
répartition géographique la géographie
électorale c'est l'étude de l'influence
de facteurs tels que la répartition des
électeurs sur le territoire les
caractéristiques géographiques d'une
circonscription ou encore les schémas de
vote régionaux c'est l'étude de
l'influence de ces facteurs sur les
résultats des élections par exemple la
géographie électorale établit que dans
la France contemporaine les régions
urbaines comme Paris Lyon et Marseille
ont tendance à voter davantage pour des
parties de gauche tandis que les régions
rurales et les petites villes votent
plutôt pour les parties de droite autre
exemple aux États-Unis il y a une
division géographique entre États
républicain qui sont dit rouge et état
démocrate qui sont dit bleus et ça c'est
aussi un résultat de la géographie
électorale
avec la géographie électorale on est
bien dans de la science politique
puisqu'il s'agit d'analyser des
observations et des données concrètes
maintenant que retenir du livre lui-même
sur la forme le tableau politique de la
France de l'Ouest d'André Siegfried est
un gros pavé de 700 pages le genre de
livre qui peut remplacer un haltère en
cas de confinement d'un côté le style
est plutôt clair le propos est structuré
efficacement le style parfois direct la
longueur des phrases varie les
paragraphes ne sont pas interminables
même plutôt courts comparé à ceux des
auteurs d'avant internet André Siegfried
ne pouvait pas utiliser de grandes
quantités de données statistiques comme
aujourd'hui mais il appuie et clarifie
son propos grâce à des cartes après la
lecture est quand même rendue
fastidieuse par l'addition des études
régionales détaillées
quelle est l'essentiel sur le fond
maintenant André sigfred cherche à
expliquer les pratiques de vote dans les
territoires de la France de l'Ouest la
Vendée la Bretagne l'Anjou l'actuel
Maine-et-Loire et le Maine entre 1871 et
1910 il analyse donc les résultats des
élections en fonction des territoires il
constate qu'il y a une continuité des
préférences politiques dans le temps
c'est-à-dire que les gens votent pour
les mêmes bords politiques c'est ce
qu'il appelle le tempérament politique
or à ses yeux le tempérament politique
tient fondamentalement à des variables
environnementales ou écologiques en
clair le vote s'explique par le milieu
dans lequel les électeurs évoluent au
quotidien l'homme comme produit de son
milieu est un paradigme très en vogue
depuis le 19e siècle
cette perspective permet à André
Siegfried delucider le vote de droite et
le vote de gauche ce qui donne sa
célèbre formule le granit vote à droite
le calcaire va à gauche
quel est le rapport entre ces matériaux
naturels et le vote prenons le granit
les terres granitiques produisent un
terrain accidenté et retiennent l'eau ce
qui permet de disperser les habitations
autour de nombreux puits cela rend
possible de grandes fermes possédées par
de grands propriétaires les communautés
sont plus se repliées sur elles-mêmes et
plus fortement hiérarchisée les gens se
rassemblent surtout à l'occasion de la
messe d'où l'influence de l'Église la
mentalité est dès lors globalement
conservatrice elle résiste au changement
politique le granit vote donc à droite
prenons maintenant le calcaire ce type
de pierre est imperméable en conséquence
de quoi les habitations doivent se
concentrer autour des rares points d'eau
cela donne une population de petits et
moyens propriétaires qui ont des
relations plus égalitaires comme les
gens se rencontrent plus facilement
l’influence de l'église est moindre cet
environnement donne une mentalité plus
ouverte au changement
voici en résumé le mécanisme de la thèse
la morphologie de l'habitat détermine
les relations entre les groupes à
l'intérieur de la société qui est une
communauté de communautés comme dit
Aristote et ses relations entre les
groupes déterminent les valeurs de la
société et donc le vote après André
Sigfried évoque aussi d'autres facteurs
il y a notamment le poids de l'histoire
par exemple l'Ouest a été marquée par la
résistance royaliste de lors de la
Révolution française il y a encore le
rapport de la campagne à la ville
le tableau politique de la France de
l'Ouest d'André sic fried est un livre
fondateur pour la science politique
contemporaine parce qu'il pose le cadre
d'analyse dans lequel la discipline se
développera au 20e siècle tout d'abord
il ne peut plus y avoir de doutes la
politique et bien l'objet d'une science
il y a des lois à découvrir voici ce
cadré Siegfried écrit dans les derniers
lignes de l'introduction d'après une
opinion courante les élections ne sont
qu'un domaine d'incohérence et de
fantaisie en les observant à la fois de
près et de haut je suis arrivé à une
conclusion contraire si selon le mot de
Goethe l'enferme même à ses lois
pourquoi la politique n'aurait-elle pas
les siennes et pour découvrir ces lois
si freed mène une étude empirique qui
repose sur un véritable travail
d'enquête il a visité les principaux
cantons et changer avec les habitants lu
les journaux locaux et consulter les
archives
ensuite ce travail est également
fondateur pour l'analyse du vote le
politiste doit distinguer les facteurs
de l'influence de l'environnement sur
les lecteurs et être tout
particulièrement attentif aux
spécificités de l'environnement local
certes le schéma précis développé dans
le tableau politique de la France de
l'Ouest ne fonctionne pas pour toutes
les régions mais la perspective
intellectuelle qui le sous-tend va
s'imposer
enfin l'analyse poussée d'André sic
fried le fait anticiper sur des idées
qui deviendront importantes en sciences
politiques comme la distinction entre la
sensibilité politique et le statut
économique de l'électeur ou encore la
tendance des responsables politiques à
manipuler la délimitation des
circonscriptions électorales à leur
bénéfice ce qu’on appelle le Jerry
mondering du nom d'un homme politique
américain el bridge Jerry qui avait
approuvé une carte électorale de forme
très étrange
cinquième référence le savant et le
politique de Max Weber
historiquement les premiers états
ressemblaient davantage à des systèmes
de raquettes organisés dans lesquelles
de puissants mafieux extorquaient des
ressources aux autochtones et leur
garantissaient en retour une protection
contre des ennemis extérieurs ou
intérieurs mais la comparaison entre un
état occidental moderne et une mafia
semble peu pertinente pourtant il y a
bien un lien c'est une des idées
profondes qui sont dans ce livre
Weber affirmait qu'il n'était pas un
homme politique et qu'il n'avait pas
l'intention de le devenir cependant
comme beaucoup de penseurs politiques il
a parfois arrivé de jouer un véritable
rôle politique il a par exemple envisagé
une candidature au Reichstag le
parlement allemand en 1918 malgré cette
ambition concrète son propos est trop
abstrait pour relever de la science
politique au sens moderne le politisme
allemand villaelle et Nice qui était un
spécialiste de la pensée de Max Weber
estime même qu'il est je cite le dernier
véritable penseur politique classique
dans la lignée de Machiavel Rousseau ou
Tocqueville que fait donc ce livre dans
ma liste et bien plusieurs de ses idées
sont essentielles dans la science
politique contemporaine au point que Max
Weber est une des références les plus
récurrentes dans les manuels
sur la forme le savant et le politique
est un des livres les plus accessibles
de Max Weber parce que c'est le texte
d'une conférence le propos est donc
relativement clair et vivant par rapport
au style académique rigoureux de
l'époque il y a des phrases courtes il y
a des questions les paragraphes sont
plutôt courts et Max Weber accompagne
son audience dans le développement de
son propos avec des phrases de
transition après certains passages sont
longs et abstraits au point que même un
lecteur avec une formation
intellectuelle doit s'accrocher quoi
retenir sur le fond maintenant je pense
qu'il y a trois choses essentielles pour
la science politique la définition de la
politique la définition du pouvoir à
travers les notions d'autorité et d'état
et la description du métier d'homme
politique tout d'abord comment Max Weber
définit-il la politique il donne sa
réponse dès le deuxième paragraphe il
commence par souligner la diversité des
sens du mot politique on parle bien de
la politique d'une banque de la
politique d'un syndicat au cours d'une
grève de la politique scolaire d'une
commune rurale et même de la politique
d'une femme qui soumet son mari Weber
estime que ce qu'il y a de crucial dans
tous différents sens c'est la domination
de l'homme par l'homme il définit donc
la politique comme l'ensemble des
efforts que l'on fait en vue de
participer au pouvoir ou d'influencer la
répartition du pouvoir soit entre les
États soit entre divers groupes au sein
d'un même État la notion de politique
est donc liée aux notions de pouvoir et
d'état Weber et Lucie de le pouvoir via
la notion d'autorité il définit
l'autorité comme la chance de faire
triompher au sein d'une relation sociale
sa propre volonté même contre la
résistance des autres or il y a une
dimension psychologique cruciale dans un
rapport d'autorité le subordonné doit
croire en la supériorité du supérieur et
en la nécessité de lui obéir c'est ce
que Weber appelle la légitimité cela
signifie que la domination du dominant
est reconnue et admise par le dominé
l'idée de la légitimité est importante
parce qu'elle permet de distinguer trois
formes d'autorité il y a tout d'abord
l'autorité qui repose sur une légitimité
traditionnelle dans ce cas le support
donné croit au caractère sacré des
traditions c'est-à-dire à tout ce que
valoriser les générations passées et
qu'elles ont transmis à leurs héritiers
et de support donner croit par
conséquent à la légitimité de ceux qui
ont été appelés par la tradition à
exercer l'autorité son obéissance est
alors personnelle il obéit aux dominant
désignés par la tradition la deuxième
forme d'autorité repose sur une
légitimité charismatique comment définir
le charisme c'est la capacité d'un
individu à fasciner d'autres individus
l’étymologie du mot Charisma grâce
accordée par Dieu signifie que le charme
de l'individu charismatique semble
surnaturel Max Weber distingue deux cas
soit c'est la personne elle-même qui est
charismatique un prophète par exemple
soit c'est la fonction qui produit le
charisme la fonction de Président de la
République française a par exemple en
elle-même la capacité nécessité de
fasciner les individus l'autorité
traditionnelle et l'autorité
charismatique sont des formes anciennes
d'autorité la dernière des trois est une
forme moderne c'est l'autorité légale
rationnel dans cet adjectif il y a
l'idée de loi parce que l'individu obéit
non pas à un autre individu mais à une
règle c'est-à-dire à une formule
générale qui prescrit ce qu'il faut
faire et puis dans l'adjectif légal
rationnel il y a aussi l’idée de raison
dont les règles tirent précisément leur
force il faut obéir aux règles parce
qu'elles sont nées de l'effort de
l'intelligence humaine dans la réalité
une autorité est toujours un mélange des
trois formes théorisées par Weber par
exemple l'autorité du Président de la
République française est traditionnel
parce que ce régime politique a une
histoire cette autorité était aussi
toujours charismatique comme La Teste
toutes les mises enseignes du pouvoir du
président enfin de nos jours elle est
surtout légale rationnelle car elle
repose sur des règles et qui ont été
élaborées méticuleusement et les
législateurs continuent de les faire
évoluer
l'exemple qui me vient spontanément à
l'esprit et celui du président de la
République parce que comme le dit Max
Weber dès le début de la conférence dans
nos sociétés le détenteur du pouvoir
politique et l'État mais qu'est-ce que
l'État on arrive là à l'idée que j'ai
évoqué au tout début le lien entre un
état et une mafia pour Max Weber l’état
ne se définit pas fondamentalement par
les acteurs personne ou entités qui le
constituent ni par les buts qu'ils
poursuit mais par le moyen spécifique
qui lui est propre le monopole de la
violence physique légitime c'est la
célèbre définition de l'état de Max
Weber je vous la cite in extenso il faut
concevoir l'état contemporain comme une
communauté humaine qui dans les limites
d'un territoire déterminé revendique
avec succès pour son propre compte le
monopole de la violence physique
légitime
historiquement l'État moderne s'est
constitué en expropriant les autorités
locales afin de centraliser le pouvoir
comme la mafia il obtient la soumission
des citoyens en leur offrant sa
protection en vertu de quoi les
violences privées sont interdites
la dernière chose essentielle pour la
science politique dans ce livre et la
description du métier d'homme politique
deux idées se sont particulièrement
imposées il y a tout d'abord les deux
éthiques où les deux morales si on veut
possible en politique l'homme politique
peut d'abord agir selon une éthique de
responsabilité cela signifie que ce sont
les résultats de son action qui lui
importe il est donc capable dans
l'esprit de Machiavel de recourir à des
moyens zimmoraux pour le bien de la
collectivité l'homme politique peut
ensuite agir selon une éthique de
conviction là au contraire ce sont ses
sentiments ces valeurs ses idées qui
déterminent son action et le problème
c'est qu'il peut faire le mal en ayant
voulu faire le bien les idéalistes qui
méconnent les contraintes de la réalité
obéissent à l'éthique de conviction
après les deux éthiques sont combinés
dans les faits comme le sont les trois
formes d'autorité
la seconde idée importante pour décrire
le métier d'homme politique tient dans
une formule célèbre ou bien on vit pour
la politique où on vit de la politique
Weber oppose par là le dirigeant qui
tire son revenu de la politique aux
militants qui en tirent son
épanouissement il y a un conflit entre
deux types d'acteurs les professionnels
et les amateurs les premiers veulent
gagner des places et des avantages les
seconds veulent faire gagner leurs idées
pour finir quelle influence ce livre
a-t-il eu en sciences politiques comme
je l'ai dit au début Max Weber n'est pas
un politiste l'abstraction de son propos
n'est pas en phase avec l'empirisme de
la science politique contemporaine pour
autant le savant et politique a été
influent à deux égards il a lancé des
thèmes et des idées sur lesquels se sont
appuyés les générations de politique
jusqu'à aujourd'hui le pouvoir que mon
relation sociale qui présuppose le
consentement du dominé l'émergence et le
développement de l'état des points de
vue historiques et sociologiques ou
encore à l'étude de la
professionnalisation de la vie politique
en second lieu le savant et le politique
témoigne du détachement que Max Weber
revendiquait à l'égard de la politique
c'était à ses yeux la condition
nécessaire à l'objectivité il avait une
liberté de parole qui lui permettait de
dire des vérités dérangeantes telles
l'origine mafieuse de l'État même s'il
ne le dit pas tel quel ou la tendance de
l'homme politique professionnelle a
sacrifié les idées pour les places les
politicistes revendiquent le même
détachement et le même recul
sixième référence the People Choice Paul
Lazarsfeld
l'avocat Juan Branco écrit en 2019 dans
crépuscule Emmanuel Macron a été placé
bien plus qu'il n'a été élu il estime
que ce sont les grands médias français
qui ont fait l'élection présidentielle
de 2017 de son point de vue les quelques
milliards qui en sont propriétaires
notamment Xavier Niel le patron
fondateur de Free c'est the ligarques de
l'Hexagone ont mis tout leur pouvoir
d’influence au service du candidat qui
devait servir au mieux leurs intérêts
mais est-il aussi simple de faire
l’opinion vous me voyez venir ce livre
de 1948 donne de sérieuses raisons d’en
douter comme le titre l’indique The
People Choice le choix du peuple en
français the people SToys parle des
facteurs qui déterminent le choix des
électeurs notamment en période
électorale il n'y a aucun doute sur le
fait qu'il s'agit bien de sciences
politiques car le contenu du livre
repose sur des interviews et des
statistiques réalisées à partir d'un
panel d'électeurs pour les élections
présidentielles américaines de 1940 et
1944 la perspective empirique de Paul
Lazarsfeld pareil d'ailleurs dont le nom
de l'Institut qu'il a fondé à la
prestigieuse Université de Columbia où
il officiers le bureau pour la recherche
sociale appliquée bref on est dans le
concret sur la forme the People Choice
est écrit avec la clarté des auteurs
américains par rapport aux auteurs
européens le style est plus simple les
phrases et les paragraphes plus courts
après comme il s'agit essentiellement de
l'analyse des résultats des enquêtes
menées par l'équipe de Paul lazarzfeld
ce n'est pas toujours passionnant et
puis il n'existe aucune traduction
française à ma connaissance
quand retenir sur le fond maintenant la
première idée essentielle du livre est
que les électeurs ont des préférences
politiques anciennes elles sont
déterminées par les caractéristiques
sociales tels que le statut
socio-économique la religion et le lieu
de résidence comme nous sommes aux
États-Unis Paul lazarzfeld donne
l’exemple des deux grands partis
américains le vote républicain est
majoritaire chez les individus de statut
élevés chez les protestants et chez les
populations rurales près des trois
quarts des électeurs républicains
correspondent ainsi à la figure du WASP
white anglo-saxon protestante blanc
anglo-saxon protestants en français en
revanche le vote démocrate est
majoritaire chez les individus de statut
peu élevé catholiques et urbain
si les préférences politiques sont
anciennes et c'est notamment en raison
de l'empreinte continue de la famille la
politique s'apprend et se pratique
d'abord en famille c'est plus
particulièrement le couple qui est
crucial les gens manifestent votent ou
s'abstiennent en couple et c'est avant
tout à l’influence respective des
conjoints l'un sur l'autre que l'on doit
l'évolution des positions politiques sur
les grands enjeux de société notez que
les femmes ont le droit de vote depuis
plus de 20 ans à l'époque de l'écriture
du livre
ainsi l'opinion du conjoint le statut la
religion et le lieu de résidence
détermine le choix de l'électeur c'est
le modèle d’interprétation du vote de
l'Université de Columbia modèle qui est
déterministe lazarzfeld écrit d'ailleurs
une personne pense politiquement comme
elle est socialement précisément parlant
plus un électeur possède certaines
caractéristiques plus il a de chances de
voter pour un parti bref ce serait ce
qu'on appelle les variables sociales
lourdes qui feraient l'élection cette
thèse détruit le mythe du citoyen qui
vote en son âme et conscience après
avoir étudié les programmes des
candidats
la seconde idée essentielle de The
People Stoy se concerne l’influence des
médias si les préférences politiques
sont anciennes et si elles procède de
facteurs sociaux durables alors
l’influence des médias est elle limitée
en effet les électeurs ne s'exposent
qu'à une partie des messages et ce sont
au contraire à les relations
personnelles qui influencent de manière
décisive leur choix le contenu
médiatique n'a défait que sur une petite
partie de l'électorat que le livre
estime à moins de 5%
. mais cette influence n’est pas
forcément négligeable elle peut même
finir par toucher les électeurs qui
n'ont jamais été exposés à un message
Lazarsfeld explique ce phénomène avec la
théorie de la communication à deux
étages selon cette théorie les messages
des médias sont reçus et filtrés par des
leaders d'opinion des individus ayant un
statut social élevé et une position
centrale au sein d'un groupe par exemple
des hommes politiques des éditorialistes
des syndicalistes mais aussi des pères
de famille ou encore des chefs
d'entreprise etc l'influence des médias
est donc indirecte un leader d'opinion
assimile leur message et le partage
ensuite avec son réseau
a eu une énorme influence en sciences
politiques il a d'abord fait du vote et
en particulier des facteurs qui le
déterminent un thème très fertile pour
le développement de la discipline il a
ensuite imposé une innovation de méthode
c'est le premier effort systématique
pour retracer le comportement des
électeurs pendant toute la durée d'une
campagne présidentielle puis mettre à
jour les données au cours des années
suivantes il a contribué à définir la
perspective intellectuelle particulière
de la science politique qui mêle la
sociologie lazarzfeld était d'ailleurs
sociologue de profession et il sera même
président de l'Association américaine de
sociologie la perspective intellectuelle
du livre mêle la sociologie et la
psychologie la mère de lazarzfeld était
psychologue et lui-même avait déjà mené
des travaux de psychologie enfin
l'influence de The People Stuart en
sciences politiques et plus généralement
dans la culture américaine tient
également à la dissipation du fantasme
de la manipulation de l'opinion publique
par les médias un fantasme bien sûr
entretenu par les communicants de la
même manière que les publicitaires
entretiennent le fantasme de la
puissance de persuasion de la publicité
septième référence les origines du
totalitarisme Anna Arendt
selon un dicton populaire allemand en
démocratie tout ce qui n'est pas
interdit et permis sous une dictature
tout ce qui n'est pas permis est
interdit et dans le totalitarisme tout
ce qui n'est pas interdit est
obligatoire c'est Mussolini qui le
premier évoque je cite ça féroce volonté
totalitaire dans un discours de 1925
trois ans après sa prise de pouvoir
l'idée est théorisée trois ans plus tard
dans la revue britannique de quant
temporary review elle voit le
totalitarisme comme étant le fait d'un
État unitaire à partie unique fasciste
ou communiste né d'une réaction au
parlementarisme mais c'est à la
philosophe et politologue Hannah Arendt
que l'on doit l'analyse de référence du
totalitarisme dans le troisième tome
intitulé Le système totalitaire de la
trilogie Les origines du totalitarisme
sorti en 1951 son objectif est de
compléter la typologie des régimes
politiques d'Aristote en théorisant un
mode de gouvernement sans précédent
comme elle se place dans la lignée
d'Aristote Anna Arendt fait plutôt de la
philosophie politique pourquoi alors
inclure ce livre dans ma liste la
première raison c'est qu'il se situe
plutôt à la frontière entre la
philosophie politique et la science
politique il y a certes un travail de
conceptualisation des phénomènes
politiques mais il y a aussi une analyse
empirique en particulier historique des
régimes totalitaires la seconde raison
c'est que ce livre est la référence
intellectuelle sur un thème à la fois
nouveau et majeur pour la science
politique à partir de la seconde partie
du 20e siècle
que dire concernant la forme au format
poche les trois tomes totalisent environ
1000 pages autrement dit il faut
s'accrocher après le propos est
accessible avec presque 10 ans
d'expérience dans le journalisme aux
États-Unis Anna Arendt sait écrire
clairement et conserver l'attention du
lecteur les phrases sont parfois longues
et compliquées certains paragraphes se
prolonge au-delà du raisonnable mais
dans l'ensemble ça va il y a peu de
jargon ce qui est certainement un autre
fruit de l'expérience journalistique de
Hannah Arendt
quelle est l'essentiel sur le fond
maintenant je vais me concentrer sur le
troisième tome le système totalitaire
parce qu'il est celui qui contient les
idées importantes pour la science
politique pour Anna Arendt le
totalitarisme est un phénomène
politiquement inédit il ne rentre dans
aucune des formes connues de despotisme
de tyrannie ou de dictatures il est la
catégorie qui permet d'expliquer les
similitudes entre le fascisme et le
communisme à élucider à travers l'étude
des cas de l'Allemagne nazie et de
l'URSS stalinienne Anna Arendt souligne
d’abord la dimension sociologique du
totalitarisme en effet elle le définit
comme un phénomène de masse c'est le
capitalisme qui en détruisant les
solidarités traditionnelles à engendrer
ces masses de grands groupes humains
déstructurés et amorphes les masses sont
aisément manipulables parce qu'elles
sont désintéressés et mentalement
confuse enfoncez dans un mélange de
nihilisme et de désirs de violence elles
sont un terrain fertile pour l'idéologie
totalitaire
le totalitarisme se concrétise
politiquement par la prédominance d'un
parti mais comment ce parti peut-il
avoir jusqu’à 90% de sympathisants pour
Anna Arendt c'est parce que le parti
totalitaire emploie des techniques de
persuasion digne d'une secte l'adhésion
massive repose sur une folie collective
entretenue par de grands rites
collectifs et non pas sur une conviction
personnelle et rationnelle l'individu
existe uniquement par son appartement
soit parti ce qui crée une intense
loyauté en pratique d’ailleurs le parti
est structuré par deux grés d'initiation
comme dans les sociétés secrètes la
dimension sectaire se tradit également
par le fait que le chef du parti a une
responsabilité totale la puissance du
parti totalitaire culmine dans la
dissolution de l'État dans le parti
unique à partir de là il n'y a plus
d'État de droit ni d'espace public
cette situation aboutit à la
déshumanisation de l'homme non seulement
le totalitarisme supprime la liberté
extérieure par la peur mais il supprime
aussi la liberté intérieure en imposant
à l'homme de donner du sens à son
existence par l'idéologie totalitaire
cela le plonge dans un mélange inédit de
désespoir et de folie carente appelle
désolation
cette conclusion philosophique est très
intéressante comme le disait déjà Platon
dans la République il y a un lien entre
le régime politique et la psychologie
individuelle ce qu’il y a dans l'esprit
de l'homme ces désirs et ses valeurs et
d'autre part la manière dont sa
communauté est organisée ce ne sont pas
du tout de sujets différents
les origines du totalitarisme est une
référence incontournable en sciences
politiques pour trois raisons
principales tout d'abord Anna Arendt met
à jour la typologie des régimes
politiques avec l'expérience du XXe
siècle ensuite elle produit une
description détaillée des mécanismes des
régimes totalitaires et enfin elle a le
courage de rapprocher le communisme et
le fascisme même si elle estime que
l'URSS de Lénine qui était une dictature
et la Chine communiste ne rentre pas
dans la catégorie du totalitarisme
petite interruption parce que je me dis
que si vous aimez l'esprit de cette
vidéo à savoir découvrir des choses
intéressantes en allant à l'essentiel et
sans se prendre la tête alors vous
aimerez probablement mon programme
Culture Express c'est un programme
méthodique pour devenir facilement une
personne cultivée en seulement quelques
mois il couvre tous les domaines de la
culture générale vous maîtriserez les
connaissances essentielles sur
l'histoire de l'humanité sur l'histoire
de France en économie en sciences
politiques en psychologie en sciences en
littérature en art en religion et en
philosophie vous ne serez plus jamais à
court de choses à dire et vous gagnerez
la confiance nécessaire pour en toute
circonstance vous pouvez en savoir plus
en cliquant sur le lien qui s'affiche en
haut à droite ou bien sur celui qui est
dans la description ou bien encore en
tapant directement l'adresse qui
s'affiche à l'écran dans la barre de
recherche et je pense que la meilleure
façon de vous donner une idée du
programme et d'écouter ce que les
membres ont à en dire Valentine et qui
reconnaît l'énorme quantité de travail
que ce programme a représenté pour moi
dit je cite que c'est une véritable mine
d'or l'essentiel est là tout est simple
pratique très bien expliqué concentré il
n'y a plus qu'à recopier et à apprendre
ce travail est vraiment formidable et
passionnant Maxence mécré directement
dans les commentaires en dessous d'une
vidéo du programme la formation est
vraiment remarquable j'étais un peu
dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas c'est un vrai
travail de synthèse que tu nous proposes
et le format vidéo est très adapté pour
moi qui est une mémoire essentiellement
auditive le choix des thèmes et des
chapitres et pertinents et je trouve que
tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite à la fois précis mais sans
fioritures vincent lui fait carrément ma
pub j'ai d'ailleurs recommandé votre
formation à ma sœur qui travaille comme
diplomate la semaine dernière elle a
déjà eu l'occasion de mettre à profit
dans ces discussions les connaissances
que vous avez diffusées vous verrez
d'autres témoignages comme ceci dans les
commentaires si vous rejoignez le
programme et si vous vous inscrivez vous
bénéficiez d'une garantie résultat une
fois que vous aurez terminé le programme
je vous rembourserai intégralement si
vous estimez que vous n'avez pas acquis
une solide culture générale si vous
voulez en savoir plus cliquez sur le
lien qui s'affiche en haut à droite ou
bien sur celui qui est dans la
description ou bien encore taper
directement l'adresse qui s'affiche à
l'écran dans la barre de recherche plus
de 800 membres ont déjà tirés parti de
ce programme et je serais ravi qu'il en
soit de même pour vous
[Musique]
huitième référence les partis politiques
de Maurice Duverger
étudiant j'avais travaillé sur les
élections présidentielles américaines et
j'avais été frappé par l'ultra
domination des deux grands partis les
démocrates et les républicains lors de
l'élection de Barack Obama en 2008 par
exemple le candidat qui arrive troisième
ne recueille que
0,56% des suffrages soit grosso modo 100
fois moins que le candidat républicain
qui arrive deuxième là c'était un peu
extrême mais de ce que je sais en
général le candidat qui arrive troisième
ne dépasse guerre quelques pour cent en
pratique c'est comme s'il n'y avait que
deux candidats à cette élection c'est
bien différent de l'élection
présidentielle française où il peut y
avoir de trois à cinq six gros candidats
ce phénomène est expliqué dans les
partis politiques de Maurice Duverger ce
livre est incontournable parce qu'il est
une référence obligée lorsque l'on parle
des partis politiques pas seulement en
sciences politiques d'ailleurs du verger
ouvre même la dixième édition qui date
de 1981 en affirmant que son travail
demeure la meilleure explication des
partis politiques malgré toutes les
théories importantes qui ont été
élaborées dans les 30 années qui se sont
écoulées depuis la première édition et
puis c'est bien de la science politique
parce que même si du verger est esquisse
une théorie générale des partis
politiques il s'appuie sur l'observation
empirique et sur l'analyse comparative
pour élaborer sa théorie il existe des
traductions en espagnol et en anglais
hors de prix sur Amazon mais le livre
n'est même plus disponible ni en papier
ni sur Kindle en français on peut le
consulter gratuitement en version pdf
sur le site de la Bibliothèque nationale
de France ce n'est pas l'idéal mais ça
permet tout de même de travailler sur le
livre
Maurice Duverger a beau être un
universitaire il a un vrai talent de
vulgarisateur il était d'ailleurs connu
pour sa capacité à simplifier des
concepts politiques complexes et allé
rendre accessibles à un large public
hormis le socle minimal de culture
politique et historique nécessaire pour
saisir les références le propos de ce
livre est très accessible du verger
écrit de manière claire et concise en
évitant les fioritures inutiles le texte
est structuré de manière logique
argument par argument avec des exemples
concrets pour étayer la théorie chaque
paragraphe commence par son idée
directrice le style de du verger a même
un certain moment une élégance
littéraire le seul défaut est celui de
l'immense majorité des auteurs de
l'époque les paragraphes sont parfois
trop longs
quoi retenir du fond de ce livre
maintenant Maurice Duverger adopte une
perspective originale à ses yeux ce ne
sont pas les idées politiques et qui
définissent les parties modernes mais la
nature de leur organisation leur
structure les parties modernes et
crient-ils se caractérise avant tout par
leur anatomie
la première idée essentielle du livre
est la célèbre distinction des deux
types de parties les parties de cadres
et les parties de masse les parties de
cadres sont apparues au 19e siècle avec
l'émergence du droit de vote et le
développement des systèmes démocratiques
comme leur nom l'indique ces parties
sont formées par des notables de la
bourgeoisie ou l'aristocratie ils sont
peu hiérarchisés parce qu'ils ont peu
d'adhérents et qu'il repose sur des
réseaux locaux de notables ce sont
traditionnellement des parties de droite
on donne en général l'exemple anglais
des parties wigs l'ancêtre du Parti
libéral de gauche et tourisme l'ancêtre
du Parti conservateur qui sont nés au
17e siècle leur but était de faire élire
leurs membres au Parlement
le second type de partie les parties de
masse est apparue à la fin du 19e siècle
et c'est parti ont connu une expansion
significative au cours du XXème siècle
ils sont nés des associations telles que
les syndicats qui recherchaient la
participation populaire et qui était
financée par cotisation comme leur nom
l'indique ils ont une large base
d'adhérents et ses adhérents viennent
forcément des classes populaires de même
il est forcément nécessaire d'organiser
la masse des adhérents c'est pourquoi
les parties de masse sont fortement
hiérarchisées la base est constituée par
des sections locales coordonnées au
niveau départemental par des fédérations
elle-même dépendantes d'un centre enfin
ils ont également la particularité de
former leurs adhérents le Parti
communiste français de l'après Seconde
Guerre mondiale est emblématique de ce
type de partie il a près de 800 000
adhérents et jouit d'une énorme
influence culturelle grâce à des centres
de formation des clubs des journaux des
maisons d'édition ou des syndicats
la troisième idée essentielle de ce
livre est moins originale du verger dit
que les partis politiques sont des
miroirs de la société plus précisément
il cristallise la structure sociale à un
moment donné encore plus précisément la
structuration des parties et leur
rapport de force reflète la
structuration il les rapports de force
des divers groupes et mouvements qui
composent la société et comme la société
est une organisation dynamique qui
évolue avec le temps la structuration de
la vie politique en partie évolue
également
comment caractériser l'influence de ce
livre sur la science politique tout
d'abord c'est la première esquisse d'une
théorie générale des parties après la
Seconde Guerre mondiale les politicistes
avaient déjà beaucoup observé et décrit
le fonctionnement des parties mais il y
avait tant de nuances et de complexité
qu'il semblait impossible de tout
synthétiser sous quelques lois du verre
à G et conscient de la difficulté il dit
au début du livre qu'une théorie
générale des parties est impossible mais
nécessaire la seconde dimension de
l'influence de ces livres et qu'il est
emblématique de l'autonomisation de la
science politique par rapport au droit
public la sociologie et l'histoire
deviennent plus importantes
[Musique]
neuvième référence the American water
Angus Campbell
à quelques jours de l'élection
présidentielle française de 2002 le
candidat centriste François Bayrou se
rend dans un quartier de Strasbourg pour
parler de sécurité la visite dérape en
un instant devant les caméras le
candidat gifle un enfant de 11 ans en
lui disant tu me fais pas les poches son
équipe de campagne est morte de peur ses
conseillé sont effondrés certains
pensent même que c'est la fin de sa
carrière politique mais c'est l'inverse
qui se produit bénéficions d'une énorme
couverture médiatique le geste fait
remonter Beyrout dans les sondages les
électeurs le voient comme un homme de
principe qui peut remédier au déclin de
l'autorité de l'État comment expliquer
l'effet de la gifle Angus Campbell avait
donné la réponse 40 ans plus tôt dans
The American Walter le psychologue
américain estime qu'au milieu des
trentes glorieuses seuls un citoyen
américain sur 10 témoigne d'une
compétence politique conforme aux
attendus de la mythologie républicaine
autrement dit les électeurs qui votent
après s'être informés sur les programmes
constitue une infime minorité mais des
auteurs qui s'opposeront à cette lui
répliqueront que je cite les électeurs
ne sont pas des imbéciles combien
dérangeantes pour la démocratie la
conclusion d'Angus Campbell a le mérite
d'être étayé the American Walter
s'inscrit dans la prolifération des
recherches sur le vote dans les années
1950 c'est bien de la science politique
car l'analyse repose sur les données
issues des élections de la décennie tout
particulièrement l'élection
présidentielle américaine de 1956 gagné
par le président en exercice Eisenhower
comme le dit le titre l'objectif du
livre est d'examiner le comportement de
l'électeur en tant qu'individu et non de
décrire à l'électorat dans son ensemble
le propos relève donc en partie de la
psychologie
avec plus de 500 pages the American
voter et dense mais accessible d'un côté
le style est formel et académique les
paragraphes sont parfois bien longs la
profondeur théorique peut intimider un
lecteur amateur de l'autre côté
toutefois Angus Campbell c’exprimer de
manière claire parfois même directe son
discours est bien structuré bref ce
n'est pas un livre à emporter à la plage
mais il n'y a pas de quoi avoir les
larmes aux yeux si pour un quelconque
travail intellectuel on doit se plonger
dans le texte
sur le fond ce livre a imposé un modèle
d'interprétation du vote de référence en
sciences politiques le modèle de
l'Université de Michigan l'Université de
l'État du nord des États-Unis dans
laquelle officier Angus Campbell ce
modèle s'oppose à celui de l'Université
de Columbia dont je vous ai parlé en
revalorisant les facteurs psychologiques
individuels il met surtout en évidence
l'importance de ce qu'il appelle
l'identification partisane c'est un
attachement d'ordre quasi affectif de
l'électeur à l'égard d'un parti d'un
programme ou d'un candidat les enquêtes
analysées dans le livre montrent que
l'identification partisane est le
principal déterminant du vote qu'il est
stable et prévisible et qui augmente
avec l'âge autrement dit plus les
lecteurs vieillit plus il s'attache à un
camp politique même si son statut social
a évolué en pratique les partisans
loyaux ont même tendance à adapter leurs
opinions sur les questions spécifiques
pour correspondre à celle de leur partie
mais comment l'identifier qu'à Sion
partisane se construit-elle c'est
l'environnement social tout
particulièrement familial qui détermine
les préférences politiques de l'électeur
du coup le choix de l'électeur
s'explique bien plus par les influences
sociales qu'il a reçu depuis son enfance
que par sa situation socio-économique au
moment du vote ce qui était la thèse du
modèle de l'Université de Columbia la
leçon essentielle de ce livre est donc
que le vote est plus une question de
sentiment que de raison les électeurs
sont plus susceptibles d'être influencés
par leur affection ou leur aversion pour
un candidat ou en partie que par la
position du candidat ou du parti sur des
questions spécifiques du coup des
personnes peu intéressées par la
politique peuvent néanmoins participer
aux élections plus par habitude que par
conviction
ces conclusions réalistes ont des
implications importantes pour les
campagnes c'est bien de défendre ses
idées et ses propositions mais il sera
plus efficace de créer ou de renforcer
un lien émotionnel avec l'électorat
the American vauter a déjà eu une grande
influence théorique il a été un modèle
pour de nombreuses études ultérieures en
matière de recherche électorale il a
également lancé le débat académique sur
la question de la rationalité de
l'électeur enfin il a eu le mérite de
souligner l'importance des facteurs
psychologiques dans le vote mais ces
conclusions ont été contestées
l'identification partisane parce qu'il
sait trop reposer sur les données de
l'élection présidentielle de 1956 or
l'identification partisane aurait été
beaucoup moins forte dans les élections
suivantes the American vauter a
également eu une influence pratique il a
encouragé les conseillers et les
communicants à faire appel au sentiment
plutôt qu'à la raison des électeurs
comme le dit le publicitaire dans le
sketch des Inconnus il ne faut jamais
prendre les gens pour des cons mais il
ne faut pas oublier qu'ils le sont
6e référence hugoven's de Robert Dahl
en 1956 le prof de sociologie de la
prestigieuse Université de Columbia
Charles right Mills publie un livre dont
le titre sonne très complotiste aux
oreilles d'un lecteur de 2023 veut power
élite qu'on peut traduire par l'élite au
pouvoir en français et le contenu est
fidèle au titre ce qui fait le succès du
livre auprès du public les idées
complotistes entre guillemets sont par
nature virale à toutes les époques
Charles right Mills affirme par exemple
que dans la démocratie américaine le
pouvoir politique étant en réalité dans
les mains d'une cinquantaine de
personnes qui circulent entre le pôle
des affaires l'état-major militaire et
le Directoire politique fédéral
autrement dit l’amérique n'est une
démocratie quand théorie dans les faits
il s'agit d'une oligarchie pour les
universitaires de la fin des années 1950
cette thèse n'est pas sérieuse
la réponse à cette thèse et hugovers de
Robert Dahl en sciences politiques ce
livre est la référence de la thèse dite
de la polyarchie selon laquelle le
pouvoir politique n'est pas monopolisé
par une minorité mais au contraire
disperser entre de multiples acteurs il
est également passé à la postérité pour
l'originalité de son approche Robert
Dahl enquête sur les processus
décisionnels dans la ville américaine de
New Haven à une centaine de kilomètres
au nord-est de New York pourquoi cette
ville tout simplement parce que c'est la
ville de la prestigieuse université Yale
dans laquelle Roberta l'épreuve
sur la forme hugoverns est un livre d'un
peu moins de 400 pages c'est un travail
académique mais c'est très lisible il
n'y a pas de jargon on retrouve le style
direct et pragmatique des auteurs
américains Robert Dahl écrit même à la
première personne le titre une très
courte question sans terme technique
qu'on peut d'ailleurs imaginer sortir de
la bouche du citoyen américain ordinaire
le titre est emblématique du ton de
l'auteur
[Musique]
centre tenant de la polyarchie roberdale
affirme qu'il y a une concurrence des
élites le pouvoir politique n'est pas
détenu par un seul groupe social
homogène mais par une multiplicité
d'élite économiques administrative ou
culturelles qui sont contraintes de
s'allier selon les circonstances et de
former des compromis pour pouvoir
diriger en ce qui concerne plus
précisément la ville de New Haven Robert
Dahl distingue plusieurs strates
historiques de dirigeants il y a d'abord
les familles traditionnellement
dominantes qu'il appelle en référence à
l'histoire romaine les patriciens mais
il y a aussi les familles émergentes
qu'il appelle donc les plébéiens et au
sein des plébéiens dalles distingue les
entrepreneurs qui se sont imposés avec
l'essor de l'industrie à la fin du 19e
siècle les représentants syndicaux ou
associatifs issus des milieux populaires
et puis des élites d'un nouveau genre
comme les bureaucrates et les experts
effectivement la structure du pouvoir
était bien oligarchique autrefois mais
l'émergence des entrepreneurs des
représentants politiques
issus des milieux populaires des
bureaucratés des experts ont transformé
la réalité du pouvoir New Haven est
devenu une polyarchie les ressources et
les moyens d'influence sont désormais
réparties entre diverses élites qui se
font concurrence pour défendre leurs
intérêts Dahl montre comment elles
interviennent dans le processus de
décision dans plusieurs enjeux
municipaux comme l'urbanisme
l'enseignement public ou la désignation
de candidats il dit même que ce ne sont
pas les élites qui ont le dernier mot en
pratique mais les administrateurs de
quartier ainsi que des élus locaux de
moindre importance
a été très influent en sciences
politiques et il a été à trois égards ce
livre fournit tout d'abord un modèle
d'études empirique les équipes de
roberdal ont mené des interviews
détaillées et ont participé en tant
qu'observateur à des prises de décision
ce livre a ensuite transformé la
perspective de la science politique sur
la question du pouvoir l'idée qui
prédominait c'est que le pouvoir était
concentré dans les mains d'une minorité
qui a la capacité d'imposer sa volonté
au reste de la société médaille montre
avec l'exemple de New Haven que le
pouvoir n'est pas concentré en 1960 soit
un an avant la publication de ce livre
notre Raymond Aron national avait déjà
écrit dans un article du journal
européen de sociologie intitulé classe
sociale classe politique classe
dirigeante que les élites sont en
réalité traversées par de nombreux
conflits et que c'est justement
l'intérêt de la démocratie que
d'organiser la compétition de différents
groupes sociaux enfin troisième
dimension de l'influence de Hugo Vans en
sciences politiques ce livre popularise
les études sur la vie politique locale
il montre comment les hommes se
gouvernent concrètement au sein d'une
communauté complexe la grande influence
de ce livre a fait de Robert Dahl un des
plus grands sinon le plus grand
politiste américain du 20e siècle
onzième référence le phénomène
bureaucratique Michel Crozier la ceita
acronyme de société d'exploitation
industrielle des tabacs et des
allumettes et l'entreprise publique qui
détenait le monopole de la production de
tabac et d'allumettes jusqu'en 1970
pendant les Trente Glorieuses elle fait
fonctionner 30 usines chacune dirigée
par deux polytechniciens recrutés à la
sortie de l'école le directeur et le
directeur adjoint tout obéit à des
règles très précises comme le directeur
est essentiellement un représentant de
l'usine dans la ville où elle est située
c'est le directeur adjoint qui assure la
direction effective de l'activité il
applique scrupuleusement les règlements
et c'est la même chose à tous les
échelons les ingénieurs appliquent
scrupuleusement les règlements les
contrôleurs techniques appliquent
scrupuleusement les règlements les chefs
d'ateliers se contentent d'enregistrer
le temps de travail de peur de se
heurter aux puissances syndicat CGT bref
l'usine est une machine ou l'initiative
n'a pas sa place
c'est en menant une étude sociologique
dans cette entreprise ainsi qu'au chèque
postaux un ancien service de la poste
qui permettait aux citoyens français qui
n'avaient pas de compte bancaire
d'effectuer des transactions financières
de base c'est en menant une étude
sociologique dans ces deux institutions
publiques la SEITA les cigarettes et les
chèques postaux que Michel Crozier tente
de décrire scientifiquement le mécanisme
de la bureaucratie le livre dont
accouche son enquête le phénomène
bureaucratique deviendra un classique en
sciences politiques parce qu'il
révolutionne la perspective sur la
bureaucratie aux yeux de Michel Crozier
la bureaucratie n'est pas un monstre de
rationalité froide mais un système
dynamique façonné par les relations
humaines
sur la forme ce livre fait un peu moins
de 400 pages comparé au style des
sociologues les plus jargonneux c'est
très accessible le ton est un personnel
peu chaleureux mais le propose le mérite
d'être clair même si les paragraphes
sont un peu longs le découpage structure
efficacement le discours sociologue
d'abord passé par HEC Michel Crozier
accompagne le lecteur à la première
personne du pluriel comme un étudiant
qui annonce les parties de sa
dissertation à la fin de l'introduction
il a beau avoir été formé aux Etats-Unis
son style garde quelque chose du style
européen plus théorique moins
pragmatique que le style des auteurs
américains
maintenant quelles sont les idées
essentielles de ce livre la première
c'est comme on peut s'y attendre étant
donné le titre une redéfinition de la
bureaucratie Max Weber en avait donné
une définition positive car en temps
plutôt il voyait la bureaucratie comme
l'incarnation au niveau de
l'administration de la rationalisation
du monde c'est une organisation purement
rationnelle donc suprêmement efficace
cette vision ne correspond pas du tout à
la dimension péjorative de notre idée de
la bureaucratie qui évoque au contraire
à l’inefficacité la théorie de Michel
Crozier est elle conforme au sens commun
moderne la raison d'être de la
bureaucratie n'est pas l'efficacité mais
la pacification des relations humaines
en effet les règles impersonnelles les
routines et la hiérarchie très
détaillées ont l'avantage de protéger
les individus des conflits le système
bureaucratique est particulièrement
stable comme si les luttes de territoire
les conflits d'intérêt ou toutes les
formes de concurrence avaient été
réglées une fois pour toutes par des
réglementations minutieuses
mais cette météorite a de gros effets
pervers il y a tout d’abord
l’inefficacité c'est-à-dire l'incapacité
à atteindre l'objectif de l'activité ce
à quoi on pourrait ajouter l'inéficiant
c'est-à-dire l'incapacité à progresser
vers l'objectif en économisant les
moyens pourquoi la bureaucratie est-elle
si peu performante parce qu'elle ne
tolère pas l'imprévu alors qu'il y a
toujours des imprévus et puis parce
qu'elle repose sur une implication
minimale du personnel d'où une faible
productivité et la médiocre qualité des
biens ou services qu'elle produit et
enfin le plus grave plus la bureaucratie
dysfonctionne plus elle persévère dans
ce qu'il a fait dysfonctionner
Michel Crozier souligne un autre effet
pervers important dont découle à la
deuxième idée essentielle du livre
malgré l'effet pacificateur de la
biocratie des conflits surviennent les
groupes hiérarchiques s'isolent les uns
des autres se transforme en cast puis
entre dans des luttes de pouvoir les uns
contre les autres ces luttes sont liées
à ce que Crozier appelle des zones
d'incertitude des zones non couvertes
par l'organisation formelle à l'échelle
de l'individu l’enjeu est de maîtriser
sa zone d'incertitude car celle-ci donne
une marge de manœuvre une faculté de
recourir à des ressources stratégiques
pour accroître le pouvoir et son
autonomie à la SEITA par exemple les
pannes de machines constituent une zone
d'incertitude pour la maîtrise de
laquelle s'oppose les ouvriers de
production et les ouvriers d'entretien
la dernière idée essentielle du livre et
la dimension culturelle de la
bureaucratie Michel Crozier estime que
c'est une forme d'organisation qui
semble bien correspondre à la mentalité
française la résistance au changement
serait un très propre de l'histoire de
France en matière économique le pays a
laissé s'épanouir un capitalisme
bourgeois essentiellement familial
valorisant fortement le prestige social
et en cela averse au risque et donc
hostile à l'innovation si elle paralyse
la société la bureaucratie serait
adaptée à l'originalité du peuple
français à la fois peu démocratique et
très individualiste du coup Michel
Crozier anticipe que la bureaucratie
française ne pourra probablement pas
être transformé de manière incrémentale
mais par crise successive
le phénomène bureaucratique n’est certes
pas un des plus grands classiques de la
science politique mais il est une
référence incontournable concernant la
bureaucratie c'est là la première
dimension de son influence il a dirigé
la réflexion vers un thème de plus en
plus important en Occident avec le
développement de l'État providence la
seconde dimension de son influence en
sciences politiques et la revalorisation
du rôle des acteurs par rapport à celui
des institutions pour le dire simplement
une organisation n'est pas un système
auquel l'individu se soumet passivement
c'est un système façonné par les
relations humaines parce que les hommes
se servent des règles pour faire
prévaloir leurs intérêts nous rejetons
trop facilement nos difficultés et écrit
Michel Crozier sur des épouvantails
abstraits comme le progrès la technique
la bureaucratie ce ne sont pas les
techniques ou les formes d'organisation
qui sont coupables ce sont les hommes
qui consciemment ou inconsciemment
participe à leur élaboration la
perspective originale du livre sera à
l'origine de la sociologie des
organisations en France
pour finir même si ce n'est pas ce
pourquoi il est passé à la postérité ce
livre est aussi très intéressant pour ce
qu'il dit du style de vie français en
étudiant la bureaucratie française
Michel Crozier met en évidence un
rapport typiquement français à
l'existence qui semble imperméable au
temps il caractérise ce rapport français
à l'existence par une grande
indépendance personnelle et une grande
lucidité intellectuelle et il estime que
cet esprit original a enrichi la
civilisation occidentale
douzième référence la logique de
l'action collective de Manku Holson le
grand syndicat médical American médical
association et particulièrement efficace
pour obtenir l'adhésion des médecins qui
exercent aux États-Unis mais il n'est
pas partisan de la méthode douce si un
médecin néglige de cotiser il perd le
soutien des avocats du syndicat et il
peut même en être la victime l'Américain
Manku Holson montre que ce type de
pression est nécessaire pour que
l'individu s'investisse dans une grande
organisation son livre La logique de
l'action collective est une référence
incontournable en sciences politiques
sur le thème de l'action collective
manucure Olson est économiste et
sociologue mais la théorie qu'il
développe dans ce livre est très utile
pour comprendre de nombreux phénomènes
sociaux et politiques dont notamment
l'abstention la mobilisation politique
ou encore l'activité des syndicats et
des groupes de pression il dit
d'ailleurs lui-même dès le premier
paragraphe de l'introduction que la
question qu'il va traiter concerne à la
fois l'économie la science politique et
la sociologie
sur la forme c'est un petit livre il
sera pourtant certainement une corvée
pour le lecteur amateur certains
sociologues font pire sur le plan du
jargon il est paragraphes ne sont pas
non plus interminables mais le propos
est donc le style de mankurolson sont
beaucoup trop théoriques d'ailleurs
quatre parties du livre sur 6
contiennent le mot théorie dans leur
titre il enchaîne parfois les
paragraphes sans un seul exemple concret
alors qu'en l'occurrence il serait très
facile d'en donner et de rendre la
démonstration plus vivante en plus les
phrases sont souvent longues ce qui rend
la lecture d'autant plus pénible mais
bon c'est un livre écrit par un
universitaire pour les universitaires
c'est une adaptation de la thèse de
doctorat dolson à Harvard et le livre
est même publié par la maison d'édition
de Harvard
que retenir du fond manurolsson disciple
fantasme de l'action collective
influencée par la mythologie
révolutionnaire notamment on s'imagine
que les membres d'un groupe agissent
comme un seul homme vers leur but commun
seulement contrairement à ce qu'affirme
Marx la communauté d'intérêt ne suffit
pas à provoquer l'action commune
permettant de promouvoir l'intérêt de
tous dans une démocratie représentative
par exemple la société a intérêt à ce
que les citoyens votent pour choisir les
gouvernants et pourtant une partie non
négligeable des électeurs s'abstiennent
comment l'expliquer et bien l'individu
ne se fond pas dans le groupe il
conserve toujours sa rationalité à lui
manquer Olson admet que les individus se
rassemblent afin de poursuivre des
objectifs qui sont incapables
d'atteindre seul mais il explique que
l'individu ne passe pas pour autant à
l'action en effet il y a une discordance
entre la rationalité individuelle et la
rationalité collective pour déterminer
s'il doit s'investir ou non l'individu
met en balance le coup et l'avantage
qu'il peut en retirer ce calcul coût
bénéfice individuel devrait être enrayer
l'action collective en effet la
stratégie la plus rationnelle pour un
membre et celle du passager clandestin
free rider en anglais qui consiste à
tenter de tirer un bénéfice de l'action
collective sans en supporter les coûts
au sens propre le passager clandestin
bénéficie du transport sans contribuer
comme les autres passagers au coût du
transport
cette stratégie a beau être la plus
rationnelle l'action collective a
pourtant lieu tel est le paradoxe de
l'action collective souligné par manuku
Olson comment expliquer ce paradoxe et
bien les groupes font comme l'American
Medical Association il motive le passage
à l'action des membres par des
incitations sélectives qui discriminent
les participants des non participants
ces incitations peuvent être matérielles
comme de l'argent des emplois des postes
de pouvoir comme dans les partis
politiques ou symboliques comme un
statut particulier elles peuvent être
positives mais aussi négatives par
exemple un médecin qui ne cotise plus à
l'American Medical Association perd la
sécurité juridique un exemple célèbre
d'incitation sélective et le système du
clause de shop en vertu duquel les
syndicats ont le monopole à l'embauche
créé aux États-Unis au début du 20e
siècle pour renforcer le pouvoir des
syndicats il a ensuite été interdit pour
que les travailleurs et la liberté de
choisir
si les incitations sélectives rendent
possible l’action collective elle
n’annule pas les stratégies
individuelles celle-ci continue
d’empoisonner la coopération de ce
problème découle une vérité essentielle
sur l’action collective plus un groupe
humain est grand moins il est enclin à
passer à l'action manurolson montre que
les petits groupes sont bien plus
efficaces en effet le bénéfice
individuel est bien plus élevé la
pression sociale est plus forte chacun
pousse les autres à participer et
l'organisation est moins compliquée et
moins coûteuse Olson estime que c'est
pour cette raison que les minorités sont
influentes en démocratie les groupes les
plus petits et créent-ils réussissent
souvent à battre les plus grands qui
dans une démocratie serait naturellement
censée l'emporter son analyse est
crédibilise plus généralement l'idée que
ce sont les petits groupes et non pas
les masques comme le pose le marxisme
qui font l'histoire Marx se désolait
qu'une partie des ouvriers anglais
continue de voter pour les conservateurs
c'est pourquoi Lénine affirmait la
nécessité d'une élite organisatrice au
sein du prolétariat
comment expliquer l’influence de la
logique de l'action collective en
sciences politiques pour faire simple
c'est le livre de référence du nouveau
paradigme d'interprétation de la
mobilisation des masses Mathieu Olson
montre en revenant au niveau de l'acteur
individuel que la logique de l'action
collective est bien plus compliquée que
ce que disent les théories qui parlent
d'un grand groupe humain le peuple ou le
prolétariat par exemple comme d'un
acteur individuel avec une volonté
unique le paradoxe qu'il souligne
éclaire bien le fait que le soutien
l'adhésion verbale à une cause par
exemple ne garantit pas du tout le
passage à l'action toky's chip dit la
date américain on pourrait le traduire
en français par les paroles ne coûte
rien
ce livre n'est pas le dernier mot sur la
question mais Oleson pose le cadre des
efforts théoriques ultérieurs ceci
approfondiront notamment la dimension
psychologique de l'action collective un
peu négligée par Olson
13e référence démocratie est
totalitarisme de Raymond Aron
ce livre est paru en 1965 mais il est
constitué de cours professés à la
Sorbonne durant l'année universitaire
1957-1958 or entre temps il s'est passé
l'instauration de la Cinquième
République par le général de Gaulle du
coup Raymond Aron donne son avis dans
l'introduction il qualifie le passage au
nouveau régime de révolution pacifique
et semi légale il dit carrément que
c'est un retour à l'Empire la Cinquième
République est plus précisément un
Empire parlementaire dans lequel la
personne du chef de l'État c'est encore
le général de Gaulle lorsquaron écrit
cette introduction la personne du chef
de l'État est plus importante que le
texte de la Constitution dans le
fonctionnement du régime Raymond Aron
dit cela pour justifier le fait que le
régime original qui est la cinquième
République ne rentre pas dans le cadre
de ses analyses si la besoin de se
justifier c'est parce que ce livre donne
une théorie générale des régimes
politiques or moins d'un an après qu'il
a élaboré sa théorie n'est un nouveau
régime un régime inédit en considération
duquel sa belle théorie risque de périmé
démocratie et totalitarisme deviendra
tout de même une référence
incontournable en sciences politiques
c'est un classique à Sciences Po et dans
les facultés c'est le premier livre que
j'ai fiché pour mon Master de
philosophie politique à la Sorbonne
effectivement le propos se situe à
l'intersection de la philosophie
politique et de la science politique
d'un côté il y a des éléments de
réflexion abstraites sur les concepts
fondamentaux du pouvoir de l'autorité du
gouvernement de l'autre côté Aaron
s'appuie sur des données empiriques des
faits historiques et il mène une analyse
comparative des régimes politiques en
étudiant comment il fonctionne dans le
monde réel
sur la forme démocratie et totalitarisme
est un livre d'un peu moins de 400 pages
plutôt dense à la lecture Aaron et
renommé pour la clarté de son propos ce
qui fait que les étudiants l'aiment
beaucoup et conservent un bon souvenir
de ses livres cependant il faut
reconnaître que divers facteurs
compliquent tout de même la lecture les
paragraphes et les phrases sont parfois
longs le vocabulaire peut dérouter par
cette technicité les références
historiques quoiquent pertinentes et
présenter clairement peuvent perdre le
lecteur et certainement davantage celui
des années 2020 que celui des années
1960 après le propos demeure étonnamment
clair en considération de sa profondeur
et je suis personnellement séduit comme
beaucoup de lecteurs par l'humilité
intellectuelle et l'antidogmatisme daron
c'est autre chose que Sartre
quelle est l'essentiel sur le fond
maintenant Raymond Aron a choisi le
titre démocratie et totalitarisme parce
que ces deux formes politiques
constituent l'antithèse de la
philosophie politique or cette antithèse
est révélatrice à plusieurs égards elle
montre que la politique est plus
importante que l'économie dans le destin
collectif elle montre également qu'il
n'existe pas de vie sociale sans
autorité organisée et plus précisément
que le style de l'autorité est
caractéristique des relations sociales
autrement dit comme le disait déjà
Platon dans la République il y a un lien
entre les valeurs les mentalités et le
régime politique
Aaron développe son propos à partir de
cette base il parle tout d'abord du
régime politique les auteurs de
référence en la matière Aristote et
Montesquieu distinguent tous les deux
les types de régimes politiques en
fonction du nombre de détenteurs du
pouvoir mais les régimes reflètent aussi
une certaine conception de la nature
humaine et du pouvoir sur quels critères
choisir un régime politique il doit être
légitime c'est à dire que les gouvernés
pensent que le détenteur du pouvoir
mérite le pouvoir et il doit être
efficace c'est-à-dire qu'il permet
d'atteindre les objectifs ainsi le
problème politique consiste
fondamentalement à justifier
l'obéissance le droit le fait par le
concept de souveraineté la philosophie
politique par l'égalité et les libertés
en pratique les régimes des pays
occidentaux légitimes l'obéissance par
la concurrence Pacifique pour l'exercice
du pouvoir à travers les élections à
travers ce mécanisme le destin de la
collectivité est pris en charge par la
collectivité elle-même mais Aaron estime
que je cite les sens même de la
politique et que des décisions soient
prises pour non par la collectivité la
question de la légitimité du régime
conduite à celle de sa potentiel
corruption Arron distingue trois espèces
de corruption celles des institutions
politiques celle de l'esprit public et
enfin celle de l'infrastructure sociale
lorsque l'organisation des interactions
individuelles dysfonctionnent une autre
classification est possible en
distinguant une tendance à l'oligarchie
et une tendance à la démagogie après un
régime politique n'est pas forcément
condamné à long terme pour Aaron le long
terme créé de la vulnérabilité mais
peut-être aussi un renforcement par la
durée la corruption et l'argument
traditionnel des adversaires
irréductibles des démocraties
entre la démocratie et le totalitarisme
permet de mieux comprendre la question
du régime politique mais quelle est la
différence fondamentale entre ces deux
pôles pour Aaron c'est la
constitutionnalité c'est à dire le fait
que le pouvoir politique repose sur un
socle de règles fondamentales
inviolables et le plus réalisme
c'est-à-dire la coexistence de diverses
opinions au sein de la société du coup
Aaron appelle les démocraties
occidentales régime constitutionnel
pluraliste les régimes ni
constitutionnels ni pluraliste en
revanche ne sont pas tous totalitaires
Arron définit le totalitarisme par 5
caractéristiques la première partie
monopolistique la deuxième une idéologie
vérité officielle de l’état troisième
caractéristique un monopole des moyens
pour l'État quatrième caractéristique
l'omniprésence de l'État puis 5ème et
dernière caractéristique la terreur
policière et idéologique de ce point de
vue le communisme et le national
socialisme avait des pratiques
équivalentes
comment résumer l'influence de ce livre
en sciences politiques sur le plan des
idées il est une des références modernes
sinon la référence moderne sur le thème
des systèmes politiques il est aussi en
termes de perspective intellectuelle le
livre le plus emblématique du fait que
la philosophie politique demeure
intéressante pour la science politique
et de l'intérêt de mêler les deux
disciplines pour traiter des questions
politiques fondamentales avec une
approche à la fois profonde et moderne
théorique et empirique enfin comme je
l'ai dit au début l'influence de
démocratie est totalitarisme tient
également au fait qu'il est devenu un
livre phare de l'enseignement de la
science politique
14e référence wymen Rebel de Ted Robert
girl
l'historien George Lefèvre ouvre son
livre La Grande Peur de 1789 à propos de
la panique et qui se répand en France à
l'été 1789 peu après le début de la
Révolution française il ouvre son livre
en parlant de l'état du peuple français
à cette époque il évoque notamment la
misérable condition des ouvriers des
villes la canailleurbaines entre
guillemets cette masse de prolétaire
inquiétée les administrateurs des
grandes villes de l'Hexagone surtout à
Paris les autorités craignaient une
révolte au moindre renchérissement du
pain et d'après le politologue américain
tais de Robert girl cette crainte était
justifiée
publié à la fin des Trente Glorieuses
whymen Rebel qu'on peut traduire en
français par pourquoi les hommes se
rebellent-ils et tu ne référence
incontournable sur le thème de la
violence politique la thèse que Ted
Robert y développe est devenu un modèle
de compréhension de l'action collective
en sciences politiques
dans son édition la plus récente wymen
rubble est un livre d'environ 450 pages
le propos est moyennement accessible
d'un côté était de Robert girl vers ce
peu dans le jargon il prévient dans
l'introduction qu'il puisera dans toutes
les sciences humaines les phrases ne
sont pas trop longues leur structure pas
trop compliquée et on retrouve
globalement le style pragmatique des
auteurs américains mais de l'autre côté
ce style pêche par son abstraction et
son académisme cœur donne l'impression
de s'adresser à ses pairs et non au
lecteur profane enfin les paragraphes
sont souvent longs
maintenant quelle est la fameuse thèse
de ce livre girl estime que les théories
sur la violence politique sont
inutilement compliquées c'est un thème
si ancien si observé et étudié à travers
le monde que nous en oublions des
facteurs psychologiques et sociaux de
base il faut donc simplifier le problème
comment guerres prend-il il met en
évidence un facteur à ses yeux
essentiels dans la violence politique
qu'il baptise la frustration relative
relective des plus-valent en anglais la
frustration c'est le fait d'avoir un
désir qu'on ne peut pas satisfaire par
exemple je me rends à la boulangerie
pour acheter un éclair à la vanille mais
la boulangerie vient de fermer c'est un
état psychologique désagréable guerre
parle lui d'une frustration relative
pour désigner l'écart perçue
négativement par les individus entre
d'une part les biens qu'ils se sentent
autorisés à convoiter et d'autre part ce
qu'ils obtiennent effectivement
obtiennent bien moins que ce qu'il pense
mériter alors la frustration grandit
leurs attentes sont souvent matérielles
le salaire la protection sociale etc
mais elles peuvent aussi être politiques
comme le dit Aristote dans les
politiques les hommes veulent avoir le
sentiment de participer au pouvoir les
attentes peuvent encore être
hiérarchiques le statut ou encore
identitaire d'après-guer plus les types
d'attente se combinent plus la
frustration est marquée
dans le détail la frustration est
relative à trois paramètres premier
paramètre à la situation deuxième
paramètre à un autre groupe social et
troisième paramètre à l'époque le
rapport entre les attentes et la réalité
varie donc beaucoup par exemple les
attentes des paysans de l'ancien régime
qui meurt de faim sont bien moins élevés
que les attentes des gilets jaunes qui
se révoltent à la fin 2018 mais la
frustration relative et comparable c'est
fondamentalement la logique du désir
humain les philosophes de l’antiquité
avaient déjà mis en lumière ce que les
scientifiques redécouvrent au début du
21e siècle en étudiant la dopamine
l'homme ne satisfait pas ses désirs dans
l'absolu mais par rapport à un niveau de
base qui évolue selon son expérience
plus il satisfait ses désirs comme
l'individu occidental moderne plus ses
attentes sont élevés plus à condition
est difficile comme le paysan de
l'ancien régime qui meurt de faim plus
ses attentes sont basses
c'est donc le niveau de base de
satisfaction qui change la frustration
elle n'est pas sensiblement différente
du révolté du XVIIIe siècle à celui du
21e siècle
le risque de violence politique survient
lorsque le décalage entre les attentes
et la réalité est trop grand alors si
les individus frustrés se rassemblent et
sous certaines conditions leur
frustration peut se transformer en une
colère visant les responsables supposés
de cette frustration la violence sociale
devient politique lorsqu'elle s'attaque
au régime politique cependant ce
changement de nature n'est pas
automatique pour qu'il s'opère il est
nécessaire que la résistance au régime
apparaissent comme légitime et que le
recours à la violence apparaisse
nécessaire pour obtenir des résultats
s'il paraît efficace alors il peut se
répandre par contagion mimétique mais le
pouvoir n'est pas impuissant il peut
contribuer à rendre la violence moins
justifiée en mettant en avant le soutien
de la population et des institutions sur
le plan pratique il peut rendre la
violence moins efficace avec des
techniques de maintien de l'ordre comme
dans les démocraties ou en réprimant
violemment les révoltes comme dans les
dictatures
quelle est l'influence de ce livre en
sciences politiques pour faire simple
c'est la référence sur le thème de la
violence publiée pour la première fois
en 1970 après une décennie de violence
politique à travers le monde il a été
réédité en 2015 parce que la thèse de la
frustration relative est toujours
pertinente pour expliquer les révoltes
du début du 21e siècle guerre évoque les
révoltes arabes du tournant des années
2010 dans son introduction à la nouvelle
édition enfin wymen Rebel illustre
également l'utilité de la science
politique pour les enjeux de sécurité sa
théorie a beau être empirique girl dit
qu'elle n'a pas vocation à être mise en
pratique mais comme il anticipe quel
risque de servir tant au révolté qu'aux
autorités il précise dans l'introduction
qu'il n'est pas responsable de ce que
les acteurs politiques en feront vous
aimez les gros manuels c'est bien c'est
pas une partie de plaisir mais comment
faire si vous voulez découvrir les idées
d'Aristote par exemple et bien aller sur
le site 1000 idées de culture générale
vous tapez Aristote dans la barre de
recherche et vous avez les synthèses des
synthèses très claires des meilleures
idées d'Aristote rédiger avec amour et
beaucoup de café par votre serviteur et
comme le nom l'indique 1000 idées de
culture générale ce n'est pas que de la
philo vous trouverez aussi les
meilleures idées en économie en
littérature en histoire en sciences
politiques en psychologie etc alors
maintenant que faire de ces gros manuels
alors moi je les garde parce qu'ils sont
bien pratiques pour remplir la
bibliothèque quand je tourne des vidéos
mais vous vous pouvez vous en servir
comme support pour poser la casserole ou
bien pour faire de la musculation si
vous n'aimez pas les haltères classiques
c'est moins fatigant que de les lire
vous n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre
la tête pour découvrir le meilleur de la
pensée allez simplement sur 1000 idées
de culture générale
15e référence the change American voter
de Norman night Sidney verba et John
petrocik
une étude menée sur les élections qui
ont eu lieu au Royaume-Uni entre 1965 et
1980 estime que deux tiers des électeurs
ont changé plusieurs fois leur choix
partisans au cours de la période ce
résultat étonnant illustre un nouveau
phénomène la volatilité électorale du
coup les théories qui expliquent le
choix des électeurs par les spécificités
de leur région par l'influence de la
famille par des variables sociales ou
encore par un attachement affectif
durable ces théories qui élucidaient la
stabilité du vote semble désormais
périmée c'est pour cette raison que le
titre de ce livre the change American
voder est un clin d'oeil à la neuvième
référence de ma liste via American voter
dans gus Campbell c'est la référence en
sciences politiques sur le thème de la
volatilité électorale c'est un travail
empirique qui repose sur les enquêtes
électorales menées au cours des années
50 et 60 par le surveille Resarch Center
de l'Université du Michigan je fais
apparaître uniquement Norman night qui
était chercheur en sciences sociales à
Stanford à l'écran mais il a pour
co-auteur son mentor Sidney verbal qui
était prof de sciences politiques à
Harvard et John petrocyc lui aussi prof
de sciences politiques mais à
l'université du Missouri un état du
centre des États-Unis
sur le plan de la forme c'est un livre
de 430 pages écrit en petit caractère le
style allait défauts d'un travail
universitaire les paragraphes sont
parfois longs le langage est parfois
technique même si ce n'est pas toujours
le cas le ton est formel en revanche les
auteurs ont le mérite de clarifier le
débat en évoquant les précédents travaux
de référence sur la question du vote
mais leur effort de rigueur rend la
lecture globalement pénible pour
l'amateur l'analyse détaillée des
résultats des enquêtes n'est pas
passionnant
maintenant quelle est l'essentiel à
retenir concernant ce livre le point de
départ de la réflexion des auteurs et
que les électeurs américains de la fin
des troncs glorieuses sont bien
différents de ceux du début de la
période tout comme la politique a changé
et crive le public a également évolué en
réponse à ce changement le public
américain du milieu des années 70
diffère fondamentalement du public des
années 50 c'est moi qui ai traduit
qu'est-ce qui a changé au niveau du vote
le choix de l'électeur n'est plus une
question d'identification partisane
comme l’affirmait Angus Campbell 15 ans
plus tôt dans The American Brother le
phénomène déterminant est désormais le
vote sur en jeu autrement dit les
lecteurs considèrent les grandes
questions politiques du moment par
exemple le chômage ou l'insécurité et il
donne sa voix aux candidat dans la
position sur ses grandes questions lui
plaît il voterait donc davantage pour
des idées
cette nouvelle attitude par rapport au
vote est en partie liée à l'histoire des
États-Unis en effet le pays connaissait
une crise politique dans les années 1960
avec les protestations contre la guerre
du Vietnam le mouvement des droits
civiques les émeuses urbaines les
assassinats de personnalités politiques
telles que John fkennedy malcomix et
Martin Luther King ou encore l'émergence
de l'écologie
mais le vote sur en jeu résulte plus
globalement de l'évolution des
mentalités occidentales l'individu est
plus autonome il pense davantage par
lui-même et de manière plus rationnelle
il est également plus individualiste ce
qui le rend sensible aux promesses
susceptibles d'améliorer sa situation
personnelle par conséquent il préfère
étudier les programmes et il le fait
dans un esprit d'indépendance par
rapport aux parties
quels sont les racines du vote sur en
jeu les auteurs en soulignent deux
principales la première racine est que
les enjeux politiques sont plus
saillants à partir de la fin des trentes
glorieuses ce qui tient aux événements
eux-mêmes mais également à une
médiatisation accrue des événements la
popularité de la télévision a explosé au
cours des années 1960 aux États-Unis la
seconde racine est la démocratisation de
l'enseignement en effet des électeurs
plus instruits sont moins fidèles aux
organisations partisanes
a marqué la science politique pour trois
raisons en premier lieu c'est un modèle
sur le plan de la méthode de travail les
auteurs ont analysé minutieusement une
grande quantité de données et cela donne
un crédit scientifique à leur conclusion
en deuxième lieu leur conclusion
renverse la perspective sur le thème du
comportement électoral le citoyen ne
vote pas par habitude il fait un choix
rationnel après s'être informé les
générations
ultérieures de politesse reprocheront à
ce livre de surestimer la rationalité de
l'électeur donc certains corrigeront le
tir 15 ans plus tard sortira un livre
intitulé the reasoning Voltaire qui
reprend la perspective de Vic changing
American botter mais avec une hypothèse
de rationalité plus réaliste selon
laquelle les lecteurs réfléchit en
faisant des raccourcis
enfin la troisième raison de l'influence
de ce livre en sciences politiques et
qu'il explique comment la profonde
transformation de la société occidentale
américaine en l'occurrence des années
1960 a transformé la psychologie de
l'électeur
16e référence la révolution silencieuse
Ronald ingel art
sur la route de Jacques Kerouac était un
de mes romans préférés à la fin de
l'adolescence comme beaucoup de lecteurs
j'étais fasciné par la liberté qui se
dégageait du voyage de l'auteur et de
son meilleur ami à travers les
États-Unis et le Mexique ce livre a
appris figuré la révolution culturelle
des années 1960 parce que c'est héros
sont de jeunes occidentaux qui
sacrifient leur conformes matériels
significatives c'est à cette évolution
des valeurs occidentales que renvoient
le beau mais peu original titre de ce
livre la révolution silencieuse l'idée
de ce titre c'est une révolution des
valeurs ne se manifeste pas par des
événements concrets donc ne fait pas de
bruit ce livre est incontournable en
sciences politiques parce qu'il est
l'explication de référence concernant la
révolution culturelle des troncs
glorieuses il s'agit bien de sciences
politiques et non pas d'un simple essai
parce que Ronald et ingel art appuie son
analyse sur une grande quantité de
données et en particulier des enquêtes
de masse qui lui permettent d'apporter
des preuves de l'évolution des valeurs
il ne sent pas l'air du temps au doigt
mouillé
sur la forme c'est un livre de 400 pages
moyennement accessibles le style est
clair les paragraphes sont bien
structurés et pas interminables
cependant le ton est académique Ronald
ingel art écrit à la première personne
du pluriel le langage est technique
parfois presque jargonneux et l'analyse
rigoureuse détaillée des résultats des
enquêtes ne peut plaire qu'aux autres
politiques pas au grand public
quelle est l'essentiel à retenir de ce
livre la révolution silencieuse lance la
théorie kingel art approfondira dans
d'autres livres la théorie dite de la
transition culturelle c'est la même idée
que celle de l'expression de révolution
culturelle qui s'est imposée dans
l'opinion publique à la nuance qu'une
transition suggère un changement plus
progressif et plus long et effectivement
on ne change pas les valeurs d'une
civilisation comme on fait un coup
d'état les hippies les révoltes
étudiantes le mouvement pour les droits
civiques etc sont des manifestations
d'une évolution plus profonde au niveau
des valeurs des populations occidentales
c'est-à-dire de la hiérarchie des choses
qui comptent à leurs yeux et qui
déterminent leur rapport à l'existence
et leur style de vie
qu'est-ce qui a changé précisément au
niveau des valeurs en s'appuyant sur une
étude comparative des systèmes
d'attitude et de hiérarchie de valeur
dans 6 pays d'Europe occidentales ingel
art constate une révolution à partir des
premières générations du baby-boom dès
la fin des années 1940 il estime que la
société occidentale est devenue poste
matérialiste ces citoyens vivent en
sécurité et mangent à leur faim donc
conformément à la pyramide des besoins
de Maslow cités par ingel Art les
Occidentaux se mettent à désirer
d'autres choses des choses qu'il ne
trouvent pas dans les supermarchés ingel
art simplifie en disant qu'il cherche
désormais la qualité de vie
mais comment l'expliquer pour ingel Art
la cause profonde et psychologique un
adulte désire ce qu'il n'avait pas lors
de son enfance or si les générations qui
n'ont pas connu la Seconde Guerre
mondiale ont grandi dans le confort
matériel elles n'ont pas connu le
confort psychologique associé à la
focalisation sur la quête des ressources
matérielles et on arrive là à la
conséquence politique de la révolution
silencieuse la vie politique change
progressivement dans l'ensemble du monde
occidental les nouvelles générations ne
se satisfont plus du modèle de sécurité
reposant sur la croissance économique
leurs attentes politiques se déplacent
notamment vers des enjeux identitaires
comme dans le mouvement des droits
civiques ou dans le féminisme et vers
des enjeux environnementaux ingel art
ajoute que les nouvelles générations
plus instruites ont également une
meilleure compétence politique ce qui
leur permet de s'impliquer davantage
dans la prise de décision
la révolution silencieuse est importante
en sciences politiques à trois égards
tout d'abord il met en valeur un thème
novateur les valeurs de la population ça
revient un peu à parler dans une
perspective moins philosophique de ce
qu'on appelle en philosophie politique
l'idéologie ou la métapolitique
c'est-à-dire les idées qui prédominent
dans les esprits des électeurs et à
travers lesquels il voit le monde et
bien sûr ces idées conditionnent leur
choix politique ensuite la révolution
silencieuse est également importante sur
le plan de la méthode en effet il est
emblématique d'une approche spéciale en
sciences politiques qui s’appelle la
politique comparative comparative
politique en anglais le principe de
cette approche est comme son nom le
suggère de comparer les systèmes
politiques les institutions les
processus et les acteurs dans différents
pays enfin ce livre est un des quelques
exemples de prédictions réussis en
sciences politiques ingel art avait
prédit que le changement
intergénérationnel dans les valeurs des
populations industrielles avancées à les
transformer la vie politique et c'est
bien ce qui s'est passé à la fin du 20e
siècle
[Musique]
17ème référence le sens caché de Daniel
gaxy il y a une dizaine d'années j'avais
été frappé en lisant un argument de Noam
Chomsky dans comprendre le pouvoir c'est
à propos de l'incompétence politique
c'est-à-dire de l'idée que les citoyens
ne seraient pas intellectuellement
compétents pour prendre des décisions
concernant le destin collectif Chomsky
donne un exemple concret à la radio
après un match de baseball aux
États-Unis le commentateur invite un
auditeur à donner ce avis sur le match
et la vie est souvent étonnamment
approfondie l'auditeur connaît toutes
les règles tous les acteurs etc il
évoque l'influence de divers facteurs
sur le résultat du match bref son
diagnostic témoigne d'une véritable
maîtrise intellectuelle de la complexité
de la situation il est compétent pour
donner un avis éclairé parce qu'il s'est
formé lui-même en s'intéressant au
baseball pourquoi demande alors Chomsky
ne ferait-il pas de même pour la
politique
Daniel gaxy donne un élément de réponse
dans le sens caché issu du verbe latin
sensérer évaluer la fortune et le rang
de chacun le sens est un filtre qui
permet de réserver les droits politiques
à certains citoyens ce filtre est le
plus souvent financier il faut avoir tel
niveau de fortune ou bien être
propriétaire ce qui est notamment
mesurable par le paiement de l'impôt
comme c'était le cas en France au début
du 19e siècle mais le filtre du sens
peut aussi être capacitaire c’est-à-dire
en pratique qu'il faut avoir tel niveau
d'éducation ou bien exercer certaines
professions la Belgique a par exemple
réservé le vote à la fin du 19e siècle à
certaines professions témoignant de
capacités intellectuelles supposées
magistrat notaire officier
le sens n'existe plus dans les
démocraties modernes mais l'idée du
titre est que dans les faits une partie
de la population est toujours exclue du
jeu démocratique seulement le phénomène
est invisible le sens caché est un livre
d'un peu plus de 250 pages il n'est pas
très agréable à lire le style est
impersonnel est théorique mais les
références à la vie politique française
rendent le propos plus dynamique la
proportion de citations paraît parfois
excessive
maintenant quel est l'essentiel à
retenir sur le fond la thèse de Daniel
gaxy et que le sentiment de compétence
politique a le même effet qu'un sens
telle est l'idée du titre les citoyens
qui s'estiment incompétents
s'intéressent moins à la politique on
parle d'une moindre politisation et ses
citoyens participent également moins à
la politique il vote moins notamment en
clair c'est de l'autocensure
comment l'expliquer c'est d'abord une
question d'éducation en effet les
professionnels de la politique
produisent des symboles que les citoyens
apprennent à déchiffrer à l'école il est
possible de l'apprendre par le seul
intérêt comme le fan de baseball de
Chomski ou par la pratique par l'action
politique mais les privilégiés du
système scolaire refusent d'admettre que
tout le monde peut être compétent en
politique le système actuel contribue
par là à la perpétuation des inégalités
Daniel gaxy plaît de donc pour la
généralisation d'un enseignement
politique qui développe la compétence
politique de la population
mais le système politique lui-même est
aussi responsable certes l'indifférence
politique recule lors de période de
politisation telles que les élections
présidentielles en France la
participation est cependant biaisée en
réalité les rituels démocratiques
cantonnent la majorité des citoyens dans
un rôle de spectateurs ils imposent les
problématiques et favorisent notamment
par l’influence des commentateurs les
opinions socialement légitimes du coup
les citoyens habituellement les plus
indifférents ne creusent pas il se
limite aux aspects les plus immédiats et
les plus personnalisés de l'élection
en fait le sens caché perpétue la
domination sociale Daniel gatsim est en
évidence le fait que dans tous les pays
occidentaux les citoyens les plus
favorisés concrètement les hommes âgés
des classes supérieures sont ceux qui se
sentent les plus légitimes pour
s'intéresser à la politique et si
impliquer le personnel politique est
quelque soit le parti sélectionner parmi
les catégories culturellement
privilégiées les classes populaires
elles tiennent des discours empruntés en
définitive les schémas de pensée des
dominants structurent la compétition
politique si bien que l’existence du
champ politique avec ses pratiques et
ses symboles suffit à reproduire la
hiérarchie sociale Daniel GACCI en
conclut que la démocratie en politique
est la même chose que la concurrence en
économie un faux nez de l'égalité
comment expliquer l'importance de ce
livre en sciences politiques le sens
caché est une référence de la sociologie
du vote qui est l'étude de l'influence
des facteurs sociaux notamment
l'éducation et l'origine
socio-économique sur le choix de
l'électeur Daniel gaxy va d'ailleurs
jusqu'à contester l'idée que les
lecteurs fait un véritable choix en
estimant qu’il est dépossédé des moyens
de connaître et de maîtriser le champ
politique ces problèmes ces acteurs ses
enjeux etc si la raison alors l'idéal de
la démocratie est illusoire puisque les
élites forment l'opinion de la
population
à mes yeux on peut voir la théorie du
sens caché comme la transposition de la
sociologie de Bourdieu sur le thème du
vote Daniel gaxy avait fréquenté le
séminaire de Bourdieu dans les années
1970 et il contribuera à importer ses
travaux en sciences politiques
18e référence la fabrication du
consentement elle doit Hermann et
noamski le film will Hunting raconte
l'histoire d'un Américain surdoué de 20
ans qui s'appelle Will Hunting il est
spécial en ce qu'il refuse le prestige
social malgré son don pour les maths et
sa vaste culture oui le vie de petit
boulot et passe son temps avec ses amis
d'enfance qui appartiennent à la
jeunesse des oeuvrets de Boston au cours
d'une séance avec le psychologue qui lui
sert de mentor will inspecte la
bibliothèque du cabinet et se moque du
caractère conformiste des livres qui s'y
trouvent et c'est quoi un de bon
livre will lui demande alors le
psychologue aquawheel répond et ben
c'est le bouquin qui vous décoiffe et
pour prouver qu'il connaît lui aussi des
références subversives le psychologue
cite la fabrication du consentement
ce livre publié en 1988 est
incontournable parce que c'est la
référence moderne sur la critique des
médias il est controversé par ce qu'il
montre que les élites démocratiques font
un large usage de la propagande ce qui
invalide le principe même de la
démocratie puisque les citoyens ne
peuvent pas prendre des décisions
éclairées cette conclusion rend le livre
éminemment subversif la propagande est à
la démocratie ce que la matraque est à
la dictature dit la célèbre citation de
Chomski pas étonnant donc qu'on ne
trouve pas ce livre dans les manuels de
sciences politiques il s'agit pourtant
bien de sciences politiques car c'est
une étude empirique des mécanismes de
pouvoir dans les démocraties modernes en
effet les équipes des auteurs Edward
Hermann un économiste prof de finances
qui a apporté son expertise financière
et Noam Chomski leurs équipes ont
analysé quantité d'articles de presse de
rapports de médias de documents
gouvernementaux et d'autres formes de
données pour mettre à jour le
fonctionnement de la propagande en
démocratie on associe en général ce
livre à Chomski parce qu'il est devenu
une star intellectuelle mondiale mais
c'est en réalité Edward Hermann qui est
à l'origine du projet
concernant la forme l'intérêt du lecteur
est stimulé par le fait que c un bouquin
qui décoiffe pour parler comme Will
Hunting mais il faut quand même
s'accrocher pour aller au bout des 600
pages le style est impersonnel et
académique ce qui n'est pas étonnant les
auteurs étant tous les deux profs dans
de prestigieuses universités le propos
est souvent technique et la plongée dans
les détails si elle donne de la force à
la démonstration n'est pas passionnant
pour l'amateur maintenant quels sont les
idées essentielles de la fabrication du
consentement Hermann et Chomski affirme
que les médias ne constituent pas un
quatrième pouvoir en démocratie dans les
faits il servent les autres pouvoirs ils
font régner une forme particulière de
désinformation dans l'intérêt des élites
politiques et économiques
Hermann et Chomski souligne d'abord la
connivence du pouvoir politique et des
médias ces derniers favorisent les
sources officielles pour paraître
objectif et pour réduire les coûts aux
États-Unis la Maison Blanche le
Pentagone et le département d’état à
Washington sont les épicentre de la
production de l'information labellisée
les grands entreprises sont également
des producteurs réguliers d'informations
jugées crédibles les sources les plus
puissantes contrôlent également les
médias en les subventionnant directement
ou indirectement ainsi l'État américain
notamment les départements de l'armée
fait bénéficier les médias de ses
largesses financières ce qui lui
garantit un accès privilégié et même un
droit de regard sur la production de
l'information
une autre manière de fabriquer le
consentement et le contrôle de
l'expertise indépendant en apparence les
experts entre guillemets médiatiques
sont souvent rémunérés comme consultants
comme employé de Fink ou par le biais du
financement de leur recherche Hermann et
Chomsky avancent que la création d'une
communauté d'experts est une technique
de propagande mise en œuvre à grande
échelle en toute connaissance de cause
ainsi les industriels américains ont
appliqué cette formule à partir des
années 1970 et 1980 en s'attachant les
services de milliers d'intellectuels
pour les catapulter dans les médias
mais le mécanisme majeur de la
propagande démocratique est le filtrage
de l'information Herman et Chomski
théoriste un modèle de propagande
comportant 5 filtres le premier filtre
et la dimension économique du média les
médias les plus puissants en forment
ainsi une strat supérieur qui produit et
diffuse une information sélectionnée
vers les strates inférieures et le
public le deuxième filtre et le poids de
la publicité qui marginalise les médias
réticents à orienter leur message dans
un sens favorable aux annonceurs le
troisième filtre et le poids des sources
jugé les plus crédibles qui sélectionne
tes formats
le quatrième filtre réside dans les
contrefeux divertibles d'organisations
voire d'individus qui ont pour fonction
de faire pression sur certains médias
sortis du rang ou sur certaines lignes
éditoriales enfin le cinquième et
dernier filtre et le filtre idéologique
principal de la société par exemple
l'anticommunisme ou la guerre contre le
terrorisme
comme je l'ai dit au début la
fabrication du consentement n'est pas
une référence conventionnelle en
sciences politiques les auteurs ont beau
être des universités réputées le contenu
du livre décoiffent trop mais cela ne
l'empêche pas d'avoir une grande
influence sur le débat aussi bien dans
la culture occidentale qu'en sciences
politiques en effet les politicistes
l'ont lu ou tout du moins connaissent
ces idées la réflexion sur le pouvoir et
le rôle des médias n'est plus la même
après l'onde de choc provoquée par ce
livre
19ème référence les trois mondes de
l'État profitant gusta espink Andersen
la société n'existe pas cette fameuse
formule de Margaret Thatcher illustre la
remise en cause de l'État-providence à
partir des années 1980 aux yeux de la
première ministre du Royaume-Uni poste
qu'elle a occupé de 1979 à 1990 à ses
yeux le citoyen doit prendre en main sa
propre vie puis éventuellement prendre
soin de son voisin mais ce n'est pas à
l'état de travailler au bien-être de sa
population cette ambition apparaît-il à
la fin du 20e siècle change profondément
les sociétés occidentales la réaction
britannique incarnée par Thatcher et la
réaction américaine incarnée par le
président Ronald Reagan illustre
également la diversité des trajectoires
nationales de l'État-providence la
France par exemple est liée à la même
époque en 1981 François Mitterrand un
président socialiste qui va renforcer
l'État-providence
c'est pour ces raisons que ce livre est
une référence incontournable en sciences
politiques il montre que
l'État-providence est un moteur
essentiel de la transformation des
sociétés occidentales et qu'il prend des
formes différentes parfois très
différentes selon les pays gusta et
Spings Andersen un sociologue danois
fait de la science politique dans la
mesure où il utilisait des méthodes de
recherche typique de la discipline
lorsqu'il compare les systèmes de
protection sociale et les politiques
publiques entre différents pays il
montre également au tout début du livre
qu'il maîtrise l'histoire des idées
politiques
comme beaucoup de livres de ma liste la
forme de celui-ci n'est pas très
attirante il est déjà assez long plus de
450 pages pour la traduction française
si le propos est accessible pour un
lecteur avec une formation
intellectuelle le style est toutefois
très impersonnel j'ai également été
frappé par le manque de fluidité on a
l'impression que les paragraphes sont
parachutés les uns après les autres bref
c'est un travail académique qui n'est
vraiment pas fait pour le grand public
mais pour les pères de l'auteur quand
retenir sur le fond je pense que deux
choses sont essentielles Costa espink
Andersen explique tout d'abord que
l'émergence de l'État-providence
correspond à une évolution du
capitalisme vers une forme plus sociale
cette évolution se résume dans le
concept de démarchandisations
l'intervention de l'État dans l'économie
et la société rend les citoyens moins
dépendants du marché si bien que le
capitalisme ne peut plus les traiter
comme des marchandises ainsi le marché
n'assure qu'une partie du bien-être de
l'individu parce que l'État-providence
le protège des forces du marché avec
cette analyse gusta espink Andersen de
la même perspective que Carl polani dans
la grande transformation l'économie de
marché a profondément transformé la
société au XIXe siècle et cette
transformation a suscité des réponses
politiques pour protéger la population
des troubles engendrés par le marché
la seconde chose essentielle dans ce
livre est la célèbre typologie des États
providence la comparaison internationale
menée par Ghosta espink Anderson lui
révèle que les systèmes nationaux de
protection sociale diffèrent par leurs
origines par leur motivation par leur
nature même mais on peut tout de même
les classifier dans des modèles le
sociologue danois font de sa typologie
sur trois critères le degré de prise en
charge du bien-être social par
l'État-providence l'influence de la
hiérarchie sociale sur la protection et
troisième critère le système familial
dominant selon ces critères il existe
trois régimes différents d'État
Providence comme le suggère le titre du
livre dans le régime libéral c'est le
besoin qui détermine la protection
l'essentiel de la couverture sociale est
acquis sur le marché du coup l'état
n'intervient que pour la production de
biens sociaux indivisibles comme la
sécurité les infrastructures ou
l'éducation la démarche enisation est
faible car l'essentiel de la protection
sociale est affectée aux individus les
plus défavorisés qui n'ont pas accès au
marché de plus les aides sont ciblées et
contribuent à stigmatiser certaines
catégorie les pauvres les assister entre
guillemets étant donné la faible
protection accordée par l'État le rôle
de la famille reste important les pays
qui correspondent le mieux à ce modèle
sont les États-Unis le Canada et
l'Australie la Suisse et le Japon
dans le régime corporatif conservateur
la qualité de la protection sociale
dépend de la profession et des revenus
on parle de modèles bismarquin de
protection sociale parce qu'il est
inspiré par les réformes sociales
financées par les cotisations
introduites par le chancelier allemand
Auto phone Bismark à la fin du 19e
siècle la démarchandisation est
partielle puisque la protection sociale
est liée à la participation préalable à
une activité salariée en vertu de quoi
ce sont les partenaires sociaux qui
gèrent le système de prestation ce
régime est indirectement redistributif
dans la mesure où les plus pauvres sont
plus touchés par les grands risques
sociaux il y a un lien important avec la
hiérarchie sociale puisque la couverture
sociale dépend de l'appartenance de
classe et du degré d'organisation
politique et sociale des salariés
l'adjectif conservateur se justifie par
le fait que la protection sociale est
pensée à l'échelle de la famille et
selon le modèle de société promue par la
religion catholique les pays les plus
représentatifs de ce modèle sont
l’autriche l'Allemagne la France
l'Italie et la Belgique
dans le régime social-démocrate la
protection sociale est universelle car
elle repose sur la citoyenneté ainsi les
prestations ne dépendent pas des revenus
et profite au pauvres comme aux riches
ce modèle de protection sociale est dit
beveridgien parce qu'il est inspiré par
le rapport beveridges rédigé en 1942 par
l’économiste socialiste britannique
William beveridges à la demande du
gouvernement britannique lequel
réfléchissait déjà à la manière de
résoudre les problèmes sociaux tels que
la pauvreté le chômage et la maladie
problèmes bien sûr exacerbé par la
guerre mondiale afin de reconstruire la
société britannique après la guerre ce
régime social-démocrate est une fusion
particulière de libéralisme et de
socialisme dans la mesure où c'est
l'État qui gère le système de prestation
le rôle du marché est très faible ce qui
permet par exemple de percevoir un
revenu de remplacement proche du salaire
d'activité lorsqu'on est au chômage la
hiérarchie sociale influe peu sur la
protection puisque la couverture et le
financement sont universels ce qui
nécessite un impôt redistributif enfin
ce régime n'est pas conservateur dans la
mesure où il favorise l'autonomie de
individu par rapport à la famille
notamment celle de la femme ce qui
correspond davantage au modèle de
société de la religion protestante les
pays les plus représentatifs de ce
modèle sont les pays scandinaves les
trois mondes de l'État-providence a eu
une grande influence sur les chercheurs
en sciences politiques même si c'est
influence a été moindre en France la
première raison de cette influence et
que Ghosta espling undersen a attiré
l'attention sur les différences parfois
considérables dans la manière dont les
états contemporains protège leur
citoyens des aléas de la vie moderne
dans la réalité il n'existe pas un
État-providence ou un état social comme
pouvait l'écrire les auteurs antérieurs
la deuxième raison de l’influence de ce
livre et que chaque pays élabore un
modèle d'État-providence en fonction de
son histoire de sa culture et de ses
mentalités enfin ce livre a eu une
grande influence en sciences politiques
parce qu'il a été séminal à l'égard de
la recherche comparée sur les États
providence c'est-à-dire qu'il a été
fondateur pour ce champ de recherche
c'est certains champs de recherche
précis mais étant donné le poids de
l'État at-providence dans les sociétés
occidentales c'est un sujet essentiel
pour comprendre le monde
20e référence principe du gouvernement
représentatif de Bernard Manin
ce n'est pas élire des gens de temps en
temps qui fait une démocratie c'est de
voter des projets estiment l'écrivain
Michel Houellebecq au début des années
2010 il répétait dans les interviews
qu'il ne voterait plus en France tant
qu'elle ne serait pas devenue une vraie
démocratie c'est-à-dire une démocratie
directe ces formules choc reprises par
les médias par exemple la France n'est
pas une démocratie de telles formules
choquée l'opinion publique française et
pourtant il existe de sérieux arguments
pour défendre l'idée qu'une démocratie
représentative n'est pas une véritable
démocratie
on trouve ces arguments dans principe du
gouvernement représentatif de Bernard
Manin ce livre est la référence
incontournable en sciences politiques
sur le thème de la démocratie
représentative et plus généralement sur
l'évolution de l'idée de démocratie dans
le contexte moderne disons après la
Révolution française comme d'autres
références de ma liste celle-ci se situe
à l'intersection de la science politique
et de la philosophie politique mais
c'est bien de la science politique parce
que Bernard Manin examine comment la
démocratie a évolué dans la pratique au
cours de l'histoire parce qu'il
s'interroge sur le fonctionnement réel
et les mécanismes spécifiques de ce
régime dans les sociétés modernes et
enfin parce qu'il ne se contente pas
d'une analyse abstraite de concepts
fondamentaux comme celui de la
représentation il aborde également leur
traduction concrète ce livre d'un peu
plus de 350 pages n'est pas une lecture
facile certes le style de Bernard Manin
est clair et ne verse presque jamais
dans le jargon mais le ton est
impersonnel le propos est dense souvent
théorique précis et techniques et les
paragraphes sont longs à mes yeux ça n'a
pas de sens de lire ce livre si on ne le
lit pas lentement en prenant des notes
et avec l'objectif de devenir un expert
sur le thème de la démocratie si Bernard
Manin n'est pas facile à lire il est en
revanche très éclairant il montre que
les sociétés contemporaines amalgames la
démocratie et le régime représentatif
les débats constitutionnels dans
lesquels intervenaient les inventeurs du
régime représentatif notamment lors des
révolutions américaines et françaises à
la fin du XVIIIe siècle ces débats
révèlent que les inventeurs du régime
représentatif n'avait en réalité pas
cherché à élaborer une forme de
démocratie en effet le régime
représentatif n'équivaut pas à une forme
de gouvernement du peuple même parler de
démocratie indirecte est une erreur le
modèle historique de la démocratie
athénienne permet de comprendre ce qui
rend un régime politique réellement
démocratique dans ce modèle le peuple ne
détient pas tous les pouvoirs mais le
tirage au sort assure légal probabilité
d'accéder à des fonctions de pouvoir ce
mode de sélection des gouvernants
présuppose que l'alternance du
commandement et de puissance ou la
rotation des charges ainsi que le
renouvellement fréquent des gouvernants
ses principes sont nécessaires pour que
le peuple reste maître de son destin en
comparaison l'élection apparaît comme un
mode de sélection aristocratique pour
autant les inventeurs des régimes
représentatifs modernes ont choisi la
sélection par l'élection sans même
débattre du tirage au sort comment
l'expliquer c'est parce que l'élection
contrairement au tirage au sort produit
le consentement des gouvernés à
l’autorité on accepte d'obéir aux
maîtres qu'on choisit et on est plus
réticent si c'est le hasard qui le
choisit
en fait le gouvernement représentatif
est un régime mixte il combine des
propriétés aristocratiques et
démocratiques cet équilibre se retrouve
dans les quatre grands principes du
gouvernement représentatif la sélection
des gouvernants par l'élection à
intervalles réguliers la relative
liberté d'action des gouvernants la
libre expression de l'opinion des
gouvernés et la mise en débat des
décisions publiques parmi ces principes
l'élection est celui qui donne au
gouvernement représentatif sa dimension
aristocratique cette dimension réside
dans la conviction que les élus ne sont
pas des citoyens ordinaires mais que
leur statut social est plus élevé que
celui des électeurs la dimension
démocratique du régime représentatif
réside elle à la fois dans l'élection
qui confère une voie égale à tout
citoyen et soumet les élites au choix du
peuple et dans la représentation en
vertu de laquelle elle est gouvernants
doivent tenir compte de l'opinion
publique
dans les faits Bernard Manin distingue
trois formes de gouvernement
représentatifs le parlementarisme la
démocratie de partie et la démocratie du
public le parlementarisme et la première
forme historique du gouvernement
représentatif il se caractérise par
l'élection d'une élite de notable puis
le gouvernement représentatif évolue
avec l'avènement des parties de masse ou
tournant du XIXe siècle l'élite sociale
des notables et remplacé par une élite
de professionnels de la politique les
militants et les hommes d'appareil enfin
le gouvernement représentatif mute
encore à la fin des années 1980 on passe
à la démocratie du public les nouvelles
techniques de communication et
l'évolution du pouvoir change le vote
les électeurs sélectionnent davantage
une personne sur son image plutôt qu'un
programme ou un camp politique l'élite
des militants et les hommes d’appareils
et donc remplacé par une élite de
figures médiatique moins proche des
électeurs cette nouvelle forme à
l'inconvénient d’accroître la distance
sociale entre les représentants et les
représentés ce qui nourrit le sentiment
d'une crise démocratique
comme ce livre a été publié il y a moins
de 30 ans il est encore un peu tôt pour
évaluer son influence mais deux éléments
me paraissent importants tout d'abord ce
livre donne une vision plus réaliste de
la démocratie la profondeur historique
est comparative de l'analyse de Bernard
Manin rétablit des nuances cruciales et
freine par là la tendance des sociétés
occidentales à idéalisé la démocratie et
puis second élément important ce livre
préfigure à l'irréflexions sur l'effet
politique des nouvelles technologies de
communication le concept de démocratie
du public apparaît particulièrement
pertinent à l'air d'Internet et des
réseaux sociaux les médias et l'opinion
publique ont désormais un rôle
prépondérant dans la vie démocratique
si vous aimez l'esprit de cette vidéo à
savoir à découvrir des choses
intéressantes en allant à l'essentiel et
sans se prendre la tête alors vous
aimerez probablement mon programme
Culture Express c'est un programme
méthodique pour devenir facilement une
personne cultivée en seulement quelques
mois il couvre tous les domaines de la
culture générale vous maîtriserez les
connaissances essentielles sur
l'histoire de l'humanité sur l'histoire
de France en économie en sciences
politiques en psychologie en sciences en
littérature en art en religion et en
philosophie vous ne serez plus jamais à
court de choses à dire et vous gagnerez
la confiance nécessaire pour briller en
toute circonstances vous pouvez en
savoir plus en cliquant sur le lien qui
s'affiche en haut à droite ou bien sûr
celui qui est dans la description ou
bien encore en tapant directement
l'adresse qui s'affiche à l'écran dans
la barre de recherche et je pense que la
meilleure façon de vous donner une idée
du programme et d'écouter ce que les
membres ont à en dire Valentine et qui
reconnaît l'énorme quantité de travail
que ce programme a représenté pour moi
dit je cite que c'est une véritable mine
d'or l'essentiel est là tout est simple
pratique très bien expliquée concentré
il n'y a plus qu'à recopier et à
apprendre ce travail est vraiment
formidable et passionnant Maxence me
crée directement dans les commentaires
en dessous d'une vidéo du programme la
formation est vraiment remarquable
j'étais un peu dubitatif étant donné le
prix initial mais je ne regrette pas
c'est un vrai travail de synthèse que tu
nous proposes et le format vidéo est
très adapté pour moi qui est une mémoire
essentiellement auditive le choix des
thèmes et des chapitres et pertinents et
je trouve que tu as trouvé la dose
d'approfondissement parfaite à la fois
précis mais sans fioriture vincent lui
fait carrément ma pub j'ai d'ailleurs
recommandé votre formation à ma soeur
qui travaille comme diplomate la semaine
dernière elle a déjà eu l'occasion de
mettre à profit dans ses discussions les
connaissances que vous avez diffusées
vous verrez d'autres témoignages comme
ceci dans les commentaires si vous
rejoignez le programme et si vous vous
inscrivez vous bénéficiez d'une garantie
résultat une fois que vous aurez terminé
le programme je vous rembourserai
intégralement si vous estimez que vous
n'avez pas acquis une solide culture
générale si vous voulez en savoir plus
cliquez sur le lien qui s'affiche en
haut à droite ou bien sur celui qui est
dans la description ou bien encore taper
directement l'adresse qui s'affiche à
l'écran dans la barre de recherche plus
de 800 membres ont déjà tirés parti de
ce programme et je serais ravi qu'il en
soit de même pour vous dans tous les cas
j'espère que la vidéo vous a plu je suis
romain et vous vous étiez sur 1000 idées
de culture générale rappelez-vous vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour vous intéresser au meilleur de
la pensée
[Musique]